This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. About a century ago, the Swiss psychiatrist Carl Jung was treating a young woman. He sat with his back to a window, listening to his patient. She told him about a dream she'd had. In it, she was given a piece of jewelry, modeled after a beetle, long considered sacred in Egyptian culture. The scarab beetle was associated in ancient Egypt with a divine force that moved the sun. Intricately carved scarab jewels was sometimes placed on the hearts of the dead to assist them in the afterlife. The young woman told the psychiatrist that in the dream,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。大约一个世纪前，瑞士精神病学家卡尔·荣格正在治疗一位年轻女性。他背对着窗户坐着，倾听着病人的诉说。她向他讲述了一个梦。在梦中，她得到了一件珠宝，其造型是一只甲虫，这种甲虫在埃及文化中长期被视为神圣之物。在古埃及，圣甲虫与推动太阳运行的神力有关。人们有时会将雕刻精美的圣甲虫珠宝放在死者的心脏上，以帮助他们进入来世。这位年轻女性告诉精神病学家，在梦中，
she was given a golden scarab. As Jung listened to the story, he heard a tapping behind him. He turned to see a flying insect knocking against the window pane. It was a beetle. In a monograph on what he called synchronicity, Carl Jung wrote, I opened the window and caught the creature in the air as it flew in. It was the nearest analog to a golden scarabular that one finds in our latitudes, a scarabia beetle, which contrary to its usual habits had evidently felt an urge to get into a dark room at this particular moment. Scientists have debated Jung's theory for decades. Many have argued that what happened in that room was nothing more than an interesting coincidence. But for Carl Jung, the beetle at the window
她得到了一只金色的圣甲虫。当荣格听着这个故事时，他听到身后传来敲击声。他转过身，看到一只飞虫正在撞击窗玻璃。那是一只甲虫。在关于他所谓的“共时性”的专著中，卡尔·荣格写道：“我打开窗户，在空中抓住了这只飞进来的生物。这是我们在这一纬度地区能找到的最接近金色圣甲虫的类似物，一只金龟子。它显然违背了平时的习性，在这一特定时刻产生了进入黑暗房间的冲动。”几十年来，科学家们一直在争论荣格的理论。许多人认为，那个房间里发生的事情只不过是一个有趣的巧合。但对于卡尔·荣格来说，窗边的甲虫
was not merely evidence that in a complex world, unusual things sometimes happened by chance. Synchronicity was a tap on the shoulder, a sign, an invitation into deeper realms of meaning and understanding. Last week on the show, we discussed the research of Columbia University psychologist Lisa Miller. Over several decades of brain imaging and other research, she's found that when we encourage our mental capacity for spiritual and transcendent thinking,
不仅仅证明了在一个复杂的世界里，不寻常的事情有时会偶然发生。共时性是一种拍肩的提醒，是一个信号，是一份通往更深层意义和理解领域的邀请。上周的节目中，我们讨论了哥伦比亚大学心理学家丽莎·米勒的研究。经过几十年的脑成像和其他研究，她发现，当我们鼓励自己进行精神和超越性思考的心理能力时，
it can have measurable effects on our brains and quantifiable benefits for our health. If you missed our earlier episode, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's titled, Waking Up Your Spiritual Brain, Part One. This week on Hidden Brain, Lisa Miller takes us on a journey of synchronicity in her own life and explains what it means to cultivate a mind that is open to the transcendent. Columbia University psychologist Lisa Miller argues that we have two capacities in our minds. One is focused on goals and achievement. She calls this the achieving brain.
它会对我们的大脑产生可测量的影响，并为我们的健康带来可量化的益处。如果你错过了我们之前的节目，可以在这个播客订阅源中找到。标题是《唤醒你的精神大脑，第一部分》。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，丽莎·米勒将带我们踏上她自己生活中的共时性之旅，并解释培养一个对超越性事物开放的心灵意味着什么。哥伦比亚大学心理学家丽莎·米勒认为，我们的头脑中有两种能力。一种专注于目标和成就。她称之为“成就大脑”。
The other is focused on meaning, connection, and transcendence. She calls this the awakened brain. Lisa argues that when we cultivate, our spiritual side, we activate three networks in the brain. These networks give us the feeling that we are loved, that we are being guided, and that we are not alone. The achieving brain might dismiss Carl Jung's synchronities using the language of probability and coincidence. But to the awakened brain, which is open to seeing connections, these events can open the door to exploration and growth. Lisa told me of a time in her own life when she
另一种专注于意义、联系和超越。她称之为“觉醒大脑”。丽莎认为，当我们培养自己的精神层面时，我们会激活大脑中的三个网络。这些网络让我们感觉到自己被爱、被引导，并且并不孤单。成就大脑可能会用概率和巧合的语言来否定卡尔·荣格的共时性。但对于觉醒大脑来说，它乐于看到各种联系，这些事件可以为探索和成长打开大门。丽莎向我讲述了她自己生活中
experienced powerful moments of synchronicity. She said that seeing these moments as signs, not just coincidences, changed her life. Shankar, this was a journey of many, many years. It was perhaps one of the most excruciating journeys of my life and certainly that of my husband as well. We were in our early 30s and we decided we wanted to become parents. So we were going to so-called try. We took a vacation to Sedona. We took a vacation to the Caribbean and eagerly awaited the good news. But in fact, there was no baby, no pregnancy, no child. And as these failed attempts, month after month, started to add up, we got a very haunting sense that, wait a minute, maybe there's something wrong. Maybe we can't conceive. And as we moved into year one and a half
经历过强大的共时性时刻。她说，将这些时刻视为信号，而不仅仅是巧合，改变了她的人生。“尚卡尔，这是一段漫长漫长的旅程。这可能是我一生中最痛苦的旅程之一，当然对我丈夫来说也是如此。我们三十出头，决定想要成为父母。所以我们打算所谓的‘尝试’。我们去塞多纳度假。我们去加勒比海度假，热切地等待着好消息。但事实上，没有婴儿，没有怀孕，没有孩子。随着这些失败的尝试，一个月又一个月，开始累积起来，我们产生了一种非常萦绕心头的预感：等等，也许有什么不对劲。也许我们无法受孕。当我们进入第一年半
and year two, we saw a fertility doctor and I checked out and he checked out my husband as being healthy. They said, we can get you pregnant, not to worry. And we did some rounds of IUIs and after that not working, strangely. It wasn't sure why. We did some rounds of IVF thinking, well, now we're going to the next phase. Surely, you know, he's healthy. I'm healthy. With an IVF will quickly conceive. And yet still no baby, no one came. The IVF process for us and our path was with every failed really non-pregnancy, it felt like a funeral. It felt like the death of our hopes and dreams.
和第二年时，我们看了生育医生，我检查了，他也检查了我丈夫，我们都很健康。他们说，‘我们可以让你怀孕，不用担心。’我们做了一些人工授精（IUI），奇怪的是，在这些尝试失败后，并不确定原因。我们做了一些试管婴儿（IVF）疗程，心想，好吧，现在我们进入下一个阶段了。肯定，你知道，他很健康。我很健康。通过试管婴儿，我们很快就会受孕。然而仍然没有婴儿，没有人到来。对我们来说，试管婴儿的过程，以及我们的道路，每一次失败的、真正的非怀孕，都感觉像是一场葬礼。它感觉像是我们希望和梦想的破灭。”
It felt like the death of that tiny little embryo that was the closest thing we had to a child. We were devastated. And this wore equally on both of us, you know, the baby showers of our friends and the little pink onesies that we would find ourselves buying for other people. It just, it was increasingly very, very depressing. I understand that in some ways this felt like a spiritual crisis to you. Can you explain why, Lisa? Shankar, as we went further down this road of trials of no child coming, right as we really were in a season of tremendous pain, I started to to notice helpers along the path and increasing synchronicities that were buoyant and guiding
“它感觉像是那个微小胚胎的死亡，那曾是我们最接近孩子的东西。我们崩溃了。这同样让我们俩都感到疲惫，你知道，朋友们的迎婴派对，我们发现自己为别人买的小粉色连体衣。这真的，越来越让人感到非常、非常沮丧。”“我理解在某些方面，这让你感觉像是一场精神危机。你能解释一下为什么吗，丽莎？”“尚卡尔，当我们在这条没有孩子到来的道路上走得越远，就在我们真正处于极度痛苦的季节时，我开始注意到路上的帮手，以及越来越多的共时性，它们是浮动的、引导性的，
along the path. There started to be more and more light in this tunnel of pure occlusion. For instance, I was on the bus once coming in late to work. I was very depressed. I'd had another failed in vitro. I couldn't even pull it out of bed. I ended up getting on the bus up to Columbia at 11 in the morning. The bus was entirely empty. I'm sitting way in the back. And suddenly someone unusual gentleman gets on. And I think, no, you're kidding me. He's walking all the way through the empty bus to the very back row to sit one seat away from me, plop down right next to me. And here I was quite depressed. I wanted to be polite. And I sat up. And he said, you know what, lady, you look like just that type of awfully nice lady that would go all around the world
沿着这条路。在这纯粹的遮蔽隧道中，开始有了越来越多的光亮。例如，有一次我乘公共汽车迟到了。我非常沮丧。我刚经历了另一次试管婴儿失败。我甚至无法从床上爬起来。我最终在上午11点坐上了去哥伦比亚大学的公共汽车。车上空无一人。我坐在最后面。突然，一个不寻常的绅士上车了。我想，不，你在开玩笑吧。他走过整辆空荡荡的公共汽车，走到最后一排，坐在离我一个座位的地方，直接在我旁边坐下。当时我非常沮丧。我想保持礼貌。我坐直了。他说，‘你知道吗，女士，你看起来就像那种会环游世界、
adopting kids. And Shankar, he got off at the next stop. Who rides a bus? One stop. One stop. My husband and I were so determined to get pregnant that we upped the ante. We went from one clinic to the next because the next clinic had slightly higher rates of conception. And after that, we went to one of the teams that had discovered in vitro,
收养孩子的善良女士。’尚卡尔，他在下一站就下车了。谁会坐一站公交车？就一站！我和我丈夫太想怀孕了，以至于我们加大了赌注。我们从一家诊所换到另一家，因为下一家诊所的受孕率略高。在那之后，我们去找了其中一个发现试管婴儿技术的团队，
working with cellular animals. And we kept going up and up and up, you will, the ladder of more sophisticated, higher rates of conception. And yet there was always a sense in my heart that for us, in our journey, on our path, we were in the wrong office. I'm wondering as you were experiencing this, Lisa, as you were going from office to office, as you were experiencing, you know, failed attempt after failed attempt. It must have been demoralizing. It must have been depressing. But just talk a little bit about the effect this had on you and your husband.
与细胞动物合作。我们不断地向上、向上、向上，如果你愿意的话，攀登更复杂、受孕率更高的阶梯。然而，我的心中总有一种感觉，对于我们，在我们的旅程中，在我们的道路上，我们走错了办公室。“我想知道，当你经历这一切时，丽莎，当你从一个办公室走到另一个办公室，当你经历着，你知道，一次又一次的失败尝试。这一定很令人沮丧。这一定很令人压抑。但请谈谈这对你和你丈夫产生的影响。”
You must have asked yourself, why is this being denied to us, this thing that so many people have around the world, you know, there are billions of human beings. Why is this gift being denied to us? Shagher, this was truly depressing. And it didn't make sense. A plus B plus C. he was healthy, I was healthy. Of course, I searched my life.
“你一定问过自己，为什么这被拒绝给我们，这种世界上那么多人拥有的东西，你知道，有数十亿人类。为什么这份礼物被拒绝给我们？”“尚卡尔，这确实令人沮丧。而且这说不通。A加B加C。他很健康，我很健康。当然，我审视了自己的生活。”
Was there something physically or perhaps morally that I'd done wrong? But there was no horrible, hard stop. It started to become clear to us through the synchronicities that kept landing in our path that maybe we were on a guided journey, as tough and as painful and without light to see. We started to feel that we were held. For instance, after an in vitro, which was by the team of all teams who had invented in vitro, we were at a very top hospital in solidarity, my husband, by my side on bed rest. And because it was only one night, we'd splurged for a very nice hotel. My husband clicks the remote, and only one channel, only one channel will show us.
“我是否在身体上或道德上做错了什么？但并没有什么可怕的、硬性的阻碍。通过不断出现在我们路上的共时性，我们开始清楚地意识到，也许我们正处于一段被引导的旅程中，尽管它艰难、痛苦，且看不到光亮。我们开始感觉到我们被守护着。例如，在一次试管婴儿之后，那是由发明试管婴儿的团队所做的，我们在一家顶级医院，我丈夫在我身边陪我卧床休息。因为只有一晚，我们挥霍住了一家非常好的酒店。我丈夫按了遥控器，只有一个频道，只有一个频道能显示，
on this TV in our overpriced hotel. He bangs the remote, he goes and fiddles with the TV. One documentary on an orphan, a little boy who lives in a garbage dump in Central America. And through the translator, the little boy says, I don't care that I live in the trash dump. I don't care that I don't go to school. But it hurts so much to not be loved that I sniff glist. to make the pain go away. And I looked at my husband and he looked at me and he said at first,
在我们那家价格过高的酒店的电视上。他拍打遥控器，他去摆弄电视。是一个关于孤儿的纪录片，一个住在中美洲垃圾堆里的小男孩。通过翻译，小男孩说，‘我不介意我住在垃圾堆里。我不介意我不去上学。但没有被爱真的很痛，所以我吸胶水，让痛苦消失。’我看着我丈夫，他看着我，他起初说，
there's a child out there for us. There was an undeniable synchronicity. What life are you showing me now? We sensed very deeply. In fact, in that moment we knew that we were on a guided journey. And synchronicity is once we acknowledged being on this journey just deepened and became more vivid and more abundant guiding us. My mother called and said,
‘有一个孩子在外面等着我们。’那是一种不可否认的共时性。‘你现在向我展示的是什么样的人生？’我们感觉得非常深刻。事实上，在那一刻，我们知道我们正处于一段被引导的旅程中。而共时性，一旦我们承认自己处于这段旅程中，就变得更加深刻，变得更加生动和丰富，引导着我们。我母亲打电话来说，
listen, I just wanted you to know my neighbor, Margaret. She just adopted the most beautiful little boy from Russia. His name is John Joseph. And, well, I just wanted you to know, honey. Bye. I mean, in some ways, Lisa, the model that you had in your head was that parenting is conception.
‘听着，我只是想让你知道，我的邻居玛格丽特。她刚从俄罗斯收养了一个最漂亮的小男孩。他的名字叫约翰·约瑟夫。嗯，我只是想让你知道，亲爱的。再见。’我的意思是，在某种程度上，丽莎，你脑子里的模式是：为人父母就是受孕。”
And really what these signals were telling you is that, no, parenting is not about conception. Parenting is about love. Love and commitment. Forever commitment and forever love is parenting. I had thought, okay, if we conceive a child, then perhaps they'll have my husband's humor and they'll have this quality that I so valued
“而这些信号真正告诉你的是，不，为人父母与受孕无关。为人父母是关于爱。爱与承诺。永远的承诺和永远的爱就是为人父母。”“我曾想，好吧，如果我们怀上一个孩子，那么也许他们会有我丈夫的幽默感，他们会有我非常看重的这种品质，
from my side of the family. And I sort of piece together in my mind the notion that parenting really was conception. But what our road of trials revealed through the bright and supportive moments of synchronicity was that parenting is love and commitment. And even more what the journey showed us was that to be someone ready to inherit parenthood, I needed to let go of a certain level of ego and control. I'll share with you that one night I was deep in sleep. When suddenly just I sat up, wide and alert, sat up straight up in bed, I felt coming a very profound, very sacred presence, moving towards me.
来自我家族的那一面。我在脑海中拼凑出一种观念，即为人父母确实就是受孕。但我们的试炼之路通过共时性中明亮而支持的时刻揭示出，为人父母是爱与承诺。更重要的是，这段旅程向我们展示了，要成为一个准备好继承父母身份的人，我需要放下一定程度的自我和控制。我与你分享，有一天我睡得很沉。突然，我坐了起来，清醒而警觉，直挺挺地坐在床上，我感觉到一种非常深刻、非常神圣的存在向我走来。”
Space opened up, there was a numinous opening, and a very clear question was asked. were pregnant now, would you adopt? In front of a presence so holy and so profound, not somber, but very serious, one would only come clean. With a full heart, I said, no, no, if I were pregnant now, I would not. And the presence was not judgmental. It just started to withdraw. Time and space closed in. It was an extraordinary experience. looked over and my husband was still out cold, totally asleep. Shankar, this presence let me know that there was something in our journey towards
“空间打开了，出现了一个神圣的开口，一个非常清晰的问题被问了出来：‘如果你现在怀孕了，你会收养吗？’在这样一个神圣而深刻的存在面前，不是阴沉，而是非常严肃，一个人只能坦诚相待。我全心全意地说，‘不，不，如果我现在怀孕了，我就不会。’而那个存在并没有评判。它只是开始撤退。时间和空间合拢了。那是一次非凡的经历。我转过头，我丈夫还在熟睡，完全睡着了。尚卡尔，这个存在让我知道，我们通往
parenthood that had to do with becoming the type of person who was really a spiritual parent. We continued further down our path, more guidance, more synchronicity is guiding us towards adoption, confirming that the doctor's office was not for us the place to become parents, when after several more months the presence came back. If you were pregnant now, would you adopt? I said, you know, I'm closer to the person who would say yes, but no. Well, around that time, we started to take measures to find the child that we knew was out there for us. We had visited an adoption agency in Pittsburgh where a clergyman's daughter,
为人父母的旅程中，有一些事情与成为一个真正精神上的父母有关。我们继续沿着我们的道路走下去，更多的引导，更多的共时性引导我们走向收养，证实了医生的办公室对我们来说不是成为父母的地方，几个月后，那个存在又回来了。‘如果你现在怀孕了，你会收养吗？’我说，‘你知道，我离那个会说“是”的人更近了，但还是不。’好吧，就在那时，我们开始采取措施寻找我们知道在外面等着我们的那个孩子。我们参观了匹兹堡的一家收养机构，那里有一位牧师的女儿，
a rabbi's daughter, had found hundreds of babies, their families. She'd helped bring families together. Her walls were lined with beautiful photos, children who were eight years old holding their violin, little babies with their new parents. The walls were full of joyful families, and I wanted to be like them. And so she sat us down, the clergyman's daughter, and she said, let's be honest here. What do you care about in a child? What do you want? And I said, well, I said, I don't care if this is a boy or a girl. I certainly don't care what race the child is, but please a child who can love. This is our first child and please a child who can love. My husband leans forward for of covers my shoulder a bit with his shoulder and says, yes, all that, but kind of a girl.
一位拉比的女儿，她已经找到了数百名婴儿，找到了他们的家庭。她帮助把家庭聚在一起。她的墙上挂满了漂亮的照片，有八岁拿着小提琴的孩子，有和新父母在一起的小婴儿。墙上挂满了快乐的家庭，我想变得像他们一样。于是她让我们坐下，那位牧师的女儿，她说，‘我们诚实一点。你关心孩子的什么？你想要什么？’我说，‘嗯，我说，我不在乎这是男孩还是女孩。我当然不在乎孩子的种族，但请一定要一个会爱的孩子。这是我们的第一个孩子，请一定要一个会爱的孩子。’我丈夫身体前倾，用他的肩膀覆盖了我的肩膀一点，说，‘是的，所有这些，但最好是个女孩。’”
And then I lean over his shoulder, right? But both of us voicing our point of view. And I said, yes, but really foremost, a child who can love. We left her office with a sense of joy and hope. We'd seen these beautiful children from all over the world who joined their parents, all of the families who'd been formed through the clergyman's daughter. Well, around that time, I was working in my office at Columbia. A couple weeks passed. And I got a call from my older cousin. My name is Lisa Jane Miller and Big Jane, my older cousin of about a decade, called to say,
“然后我越过他的肩膀，对吧？我们俩都表达了自己的观点。我说，‘是的，但真的最重要的是，一个会爱的孩子。’我们带着喜悦和希望离开了她的办公室。我们看到了这些来自世界各地加入他们父母的美丽孩子，所有通过这位牧师的女儿组成的家庭。好吧，就在那时，我在哥伦比亚大学的办公室工作。几周过去了。我接到了我大表姐的电话。我的名字是丽莎·简·米勒，大简，我大十岁左右的表姐，打电话来说，
You know what, little Cahs? I know you're sitting there in your office, running your numbers, studying spirituality. But if you really want to know spirituality, I think you need to get out of your office, get on a plane, and come out here to South Dakota to attend a healing ceremony. My good colleague, the chief of the Lakota, has said, I can bring you. And I know you've been looking for your child. I think this is another approach. I think you should come out here. I canceled all my appointments at Columbia.
‘你知道吗，小简？我知道你坐在办公室里，算着你的数字，研究灵性。但如果你真的想了解灵性，我认为你需要走出办公室，坐上飞机，来到南达科他州参加一个治愈仪式。我的好同事，拉科塔部落的首领，说我可以带你去。我知道你一直在寻找你的孩子。我认为这是另一种方法。我认为你应该来这里。’我取消了在哥伦比亚大学的所有预约。”
I got on a plane. I went out to South Dakota. And there in the healing ceremony, the men moved into one anipi, the women into another. And in the women's innipe, the leader who identified herself as the medicine man's wife, led us through a series of prayers. At one point, she asked us to go around the circle inside the Inepe. each of us in turn to say why we had come to the healing ceremony. The first woman spoke. She said, I am here because my son is 14.
“我坐上了飞机。我去了南达科他州。在那里，在治愈仪式上，男人们进入一个汗屋（Inipi），女人们进入另一个。在女人的汗屋里，自称是巫医妻子的领队带领我们进行了一系列祈祷。在某个时刻，她要求我们绕着汗屋里的圆圈走，每个人轮流说出我们为什么来参加治愈仪式。第一个女人说话了。她说，‘我在这里是因为我的儿子14岁了。’”
He's starting to smoke and use drugs, and I really worry about him. The next woman spoke. My son is 40. He's not coming home. I worry for the family. Around the circle, each woman had come that day to pray for her son. until we got to my immediate left, Big Jane, my cousin, who spoke for me, which as a full-time talker as a professor, was actually most welcome.
“‘他开始抽烟和吸毒，我真的很担心他。’下一个女人说话了。‘我的儿子40岁了。他不回家。我为这个家庭担心。’绕着圆圈，每个女人那天都是来为她的儿子祈祷的。直到轮到我左边的表姐大简，她替我说了话，作为一个全职的演讲者和教授，这实际上是最受欢迎的。”
This is my cousin, little Jane. She has come looking for her child. I'm wondering if we could help her find her child. All of the women looked me in the eye. for the first time I knew I was in the right place. We then were led in a prayer that was to hold all of the prayers of the women and was sent up through the top of the Anipi. And at Shankar, we received a call that night.
“‘这是我的表妹，小简。她来寻找她的孩子。我想知道我们是否能帮她找到她的孩子。’所有的女人都看着我的眼睛。第一次，我知道我来对地方了。然后我们被引导进行了一次祈祷，旨在容纳所有女人的祈祷，并通过汗屋的顶部送上去。尚卡尔，那天晚上我们接到了一个电话。”
That night that the prayer had been sent up through the Inipi, that night we received a call to my phone machine, in New York from the other side of the world. We have found the Miller's child. We know Mr. Miller had wanted a girl, and there's many wonderful girls. We can get you a girl, but this is the Miller's child. This is the Miller's child, and it is a son. Five years of struggle and sorrow and weeping and infertility.
“那天晚上，祈祷通过汗屋送上去的那天晚上，我们接到了一个电话，打到我在纽约的电话答录机上，来自世界的另一端。‘我们找到了米勒家的孩子。我们知道米勒先生想要一个女孩，有很多很棒的女孩。我们可以给你一个女孩，但这是米勒家的孩子。这是米勒家的孩子，而且是一个儿子。’五年的挣扎、悲伤、哭泣和不孕。”
I couldn't wait to see his photo. I couldn't wait to see his video. I was home in a couple days. The video came. I opened my eyes to see the most joyful, da, da, da, da, little boy with his arm around the nurse, glowing with joy, glowing with energy, dot, da, da. I fell in love. Shankar, in that moment, I became a parent. Profound love, a soaring love like I'd never felt before, a tidal wave of soaring love.
“我迫不及待地想看到他的照片。我迫不及待地想看到他的视频。几天后我就回家了。视频来了。我睁开眼睛，看到那个最快乐的、哒哒哒哒的小男孩，他搂着护士的胳膊，洋溢着喜悦，洋溢着活力，哒哒哒。我坠入爱河了。尚卡尔，在那一刻，我成为了父母。深刻的爱，一种我从未感受过的飞升的爱，一股飞升的爱的潮汐。”
and I was sure, deeply committed in my heart that this is my spiritual child. That very night that I saw the video and made the commitment in my heart and loved like I'd never loved before, the presence came back a third time. If you were pregnant now, would you adopt? Absolutely. Absolutely, this is my spiritual child. Time and space closed in. And I looked over once again, my husband was out cold. But I poked him. I woke him up. And that very night, Shankar, after five years of the best clinics in the United States, the very night that we had committed to adopt our boy from the other side of the world, a girl came to us through natural conception. spiritual twins. That's extraordinary, Lisa.
“我确信，我心中深深地承诺，这是我的精神之子。就在我看到视频并做出心中承诺，爱得前所未有的那个晚上，那个存在第三次出现了。‘如果你现在怀孕了，你会收养吗？’‘绝对会。绝对会，这是我的精神之子。’时间和空间合拢了。我再次看过去，我丈夫睡得死死的。但我戳了他一下。我把他叫醒了。就在那个晚上，尚卡尔，在美国最好的诊所治疗五年后，就在我们承诺收养我们来自世界另一端的男孩的那个晚上，一个女孩通过自然受孕来到了我们身边。精神双胞胎。那太非凡了，丽莎。”
Well, to this day, I feel profoundly grateful for every bit, foremost, of course, for Isaiah and Leah, the spiritual twins. And one more came down the road, Lila. I also feel grateful for the road of trials that wore away the illusions of ego and outcome and radical control
“嗯，直到今天，我仍然对每一件事深感感激，当然，最重要的是对以赛亚和莉亚，这对精神双胞胎。后来又来了一个，莱拉。我也对那段磨损了自我、结果和激进控制的幻觉的试炼之路感到感激。”
and opened the gateway to awakened awareness that opened a dialogue that is how I now live my life. And I have realized through three decades now of science, we all are equipped to live in dialogue. Had I simply said, my, what a coincidence, the orphan in the garbage dump, my, what a striking synchronicity, but we'll leave it at that,
“它打开了通往觉醒意识的门户，开启了一场对话，这就是我现在生活的方式。通过三十年的科学研究，我意识到，我们所有人都具备进行对话的能力。如果我只是说，‘哎呀，真是个巧合，垃圾堆里的孤儿，哎呀，真是个惊人的共时性，但就这样吧，’”
the fellow on the bus. Wow, I wonder if this mystical experience is really, Hmm, interesting, but tucked it in the back drawer of my mind. Had I only treated awakened awareness as a spectator sport, I might have missed the opportunity of our lifetimes. Had I only treated the synchronicities, the mystical experiences, as interesting or, wow, wonderful, but set them aside, tucked them into a back drawer in my mind,
“‘那个公交车上的家伙。哇，我不知道这种神秘体验是否是真的，嗯，很有趣，’但把它塞进我脑海的后抽屉里。如果我只是把觉醒意识当作一项观众运动，我可能就错过了我们一生中的机会。如果我只是把共时性、神秘体验当作有趣或‘哇，太棒了’，但把它们放在一边，塞进我脑海的后抽屉里，”
it would not have been enough. Isaiah would have still been in an orphanage, in time he would have been adopted into the military, and we would not be a family. Our family, the most important center of my life, our family was born out of a dialogue with the deeper force of all life. Lisa says that people with well-developed spiritual lives are healthier, happier, and more connected to others. But how do we go about exploring this dimension of existence? When we come back, how to cultivate an awakened brain. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
“那是不够的。以赛亚仍然会在孤儿院里，随着时间的推移，他会被送进军队，而我们也不会成为一个家庭。我们的家庭，我生命中最重要的中心，我们的家庭诞生于与所有生命更深层力量的对话中。丽莎说，精神生活丰富的人更健康、更快乐，与他人的联系也更紧密。但我们该如何探索这一存在的维度呢？回来后，我们将探讨如何培养一个觉醒的大脑。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。”
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had experiences in your life when you felt helped or hindered by your own spirituality? If you have a personal story that you would be willing to share with a hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at Feedback at Hidden Brain.org using the subject line, spiritual.
“我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你的生活中是否有过这样的经历：你感到自己的灵性在帮助你或阻碍你？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者对本集有任何问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是Feedback@HiddenBrain.org，主题行请使用‘spiritual’。”
Again, that's Feedback at HiddenBrain.org. Lisa Miller is a psychologist at Teachers College Columbia University. She's the author of The Awakened Brain, the new science of spirituality, and our quest for an inspired life. Lisa, you say that one way we can strengthen our awakened awareness is by engaging regularly in spiritual disciplines. What are some of these disciplines and how do they affect us? Prayer, meditation, right action.
“再说一遍，是Feedback@HiddenBrain.org。丽莎·米勒是哥伦比亚大学师范学院的心理学家。她是《觉醒的大脑：灵性的新科学，以及我们对灵感生活的追求》一书的作者。丽莎，你说我们可以通过定期参与精神修行来加强我们的觉醒意识。这些修行有哪些，它们是如何影响我们的？祈祷、冥想、正行。”
Our spiritual practices can be held within the embrace of our faith tradition or held by multiple faith traditions or our spiritual life can be outside of religion. But whether or not we are religious, spiritual practice, literally builds the muscle, if you will, strengthens the cortex of the awakened brain. You argue that in order to do this, you actually have to build a regular practice.
“我们的精神修行可以包含在我们的信仰传统中，也可以由多种信仰传统所支持，或者我们的精神生活可以存在于宗教之外。但无论我们是否信教，精神修行实际上是在锻炼肌肉，如果你愿意的话，它加强了觉醒大脑的皮层。”“你认为为了做到这一点，你实际上必须建立一种定期的修行。”
So this is a little bit like going to the gym. You can't just do it a day or two and say, okay, I've checked the box now. When we looked at people who said, yes, yes, I'm spiritual, but only set it on one day. We happened to have only asked them one day. We did not see neural correlates.
“所以这有点像去健身房。你不能只做一两天就说，‘好吧，我现在已经完成了。’当我们观察那些说‘是的，是的，我是有灵性的，’但只在某一天提到它的人时。我们碰巧只问了他们一天。我们没有看到神经相关性。”
We did not see a stronger cortex in people who on any given day raise their hand and say, yes, yes, spirituality is important to me. It's when people day after day over in our study eight years said, yes, spirituality is important to me day in and day out, that we saw a thicker cortex processing power across the regions of the awakened brain. In other words, it is sustained spiritual life that seems to go hand in hand with a deepening of our awakened awareness. It becomes a new normal. Through prayer, through meditation, we access the deeper nature of life and our capacity to perceive into the sacred reality becomes a new normal, becomes a new set point. In fact, Shankar, together with my colleagues in the medical school, Merda Weissman and her team, we looked at people who struggled with severe depression and those who did not, and all of their children and grandchildren.
“我们没有在那些在任何特定日子举手说‘是的，是的，灵性对我很重要’的人身上看到更强的皮层。只有当人们日复一日，在我们的研究中长达八年，说‘是的，灵性对我很重要，日复一日’时，我们才看到觉醒大脑区域中更厚的皮层处理能力。换句话说，是持续的精神生活似乎与我们觉醒意识的加深齐头并进。它成为了一种新的常态。通过祈祷，通过冥想，我们接触到生命的更深层本质，我们感知神圣现实的能力成为了一种新的常态，成为了一个新的设定点。事实上，尚卡尔，我和医学院的同事默达·韦斯曼及其团队一起，观察了那些与严重抑郁症作斗争的人和那些没有的人，以及他们所有的孩子和孙辈。”
Over 40 years, Murdo Weissman generously shared her 40-year longitudinal three-generation data set through which we could follow people over the course of their life, those who were at high risk for depression and those who were at low risk for depression. And what we found was that in the course of life, many of us face periods of despair, suffering, major depression. If in these moments of great despair, we start to ask the deep existential questions, what is the meaning of my life? What will be my spiritual footprint? What is the nature of reality? So not just what is meaning and purpose, but ultimate meaning sacred purpose.
“在40年的时间里，默达·韦斯曼慷慨地分享了她40年的纵向三代数据集，通过这些数据，我们可以追踪人们一生的轨迹，那些患抑郁症高风险的人和低风险的人。我们发现，在人生的过程中，我们许多人都会面临绝望、痛苦、重度抑郁的时期。如果在这些极度绝望的时刻，我们开始问那些深刻的存在主义问题：‘我生命的意义是什么？我将留下什么样的精神足迹？现实的本质是什么？’所以不仅仅是意义和目的，而是终极意义、神圣目的。”
Who am I? And what is the world in the relationship to the source itself of life? It can even be the case that depression potentiates spiritual growth. Our brain is built so that in moments of despair, we are potentated to widen the aperture and let in more light. and start to awaken spiritually. In my collaboration with Merna Weissman and her team, we found that those people who have a very strong spirituality today
“‘我是谁？世界与生命本身的源头有什么关系？’甚至可能出现抑郁症促进精神成长的情况。我们的大脑构造使得在绝望的时刻，我们被赋予了拓宽视野、让更多光亮进入的能力，并开始在精神上觉醒。在与默达·韦斯曼及其团队的合作中，我们发现，那些今天拥有非常强大灵性的人，”
are two and a half times more likely to have gotten there through the road of trials, through a major depression. In other words, people who say, yes, I turn to God for guidance. I have a very strong relationship, a lived-felt relationship with my higher power, the universe, are 250% more likely in the past 10 years to have come through a major depression. A spiritual response to suffering once formed becomes the new way to lean into life. It becomes the go-to way to look into the deeper nature of life, betrayal, disappointment, loss.
“有2.5倍的可能性是通过试炼之路，通过重度抑郁症走到这一步的。换句话说，那些说‘是的，我向神寻求指导。我与我的更高力量、宇宙有着非常强烈的、生活感知的关系’的人，在过去10年中经历过重度抑郁症的可能性要高出250%。一旦形成，对痛苦的精神回应就成了拥抱生活的新方式。它成了审视生命更深层本质、背叛、失望、损失的首选方式。”
What life are you showing me now? How can I love more deeply? A spiritual response to suffering. The red door I wanted so much is stuck. It slammed shut and I can't go where I've always wanted to go or I wanted my child to go. But hey, look over there. There is a wide open. I didn't even know they existed, yellow door.
“‘你现在向我展示的是什么样的人生？我该如何更深地去爱？’对痛苦的精神回应。我非常想要的红门卡住了。它砰地关上了，我无法去我一直想去的地方，或者我想要我的孩子去的地方。但是嘿，看那边。有一扇宽敞的、我甚至不知道它存在的黄门。”
A yellow door that has a new career, a new community, a new partner beyond what I even knew existed. This is a dialogue, a lived dialogue with life that takes us out of the finite achieving mind and into the awakened mind. You talk about helping a patient named Bev in your therapy practice develop what you call heart knowing, going beyond the rational, the intellectual knowing to heart knowing. Paint me a picture of Bev's story. So Bev came in, tormented by a decision she had to make. so much so that it weighed on her heart, it was making her anxious. Bev had raised three of her four children. Her youngest child, a daughter was still at home.
“一扇有着新职业、新社区、新伴侣的黄门，超出了我所知的范围。这是一场对话，一场与生命的生活对话，它将我们从有限的成就头脑带入觉醒的头脑。你谈到在你的治疗实践中帮助一位名叫贝芙的病人发展你所谓的‘心知’，超越理性的、智力的认知，达到心知。请为我描绘一下贝芙的故事。”“所以贝芙进来了，被她必须做出的决定折磨着。以至于它压在她的心头，让她感到焦虑。贝芙抚养了四个孩子中的三个。她最小的孩子，一个女儿还在家里。”
And right at the time where she had wanted to try to connect with her daughter, she'd felt a certain distance between her and her fourth child that she'd not felt towards the other. She described a blended feeling that she felt with the oldest three. And the fourth seemed more distant. disconnected. Bev had hoped that now that her fourth child was in high school, she could clear time to really just focus on her and that a bond might form that they could be in this intimate way, just the two of them for this passage. But right at that time, she was given a very unexpected
“就在她想尝试与女儿建立联系的时候，她感觉到她和第四个孩子之间有一种她对其他孩子没有感受到的距离感。她描述了她与前三个孩子之间那种混合的感觉。而第四个孩子似乎更疏远、更断联。贝芙曾希望，既然她的第四个孩子上高中了，她可以腾出时间真正专注于她，并且在这段时期，她们俩可以以这种亲密的方式建立纽带。但就在那时，她得到了一个非常意外的”
offer of promotion, a promotion that would have required 15 more hours of work a week, a promotion that she felt honored her abilities. She was proud to receive the promotion, but tremendously concerned that it was going to cut into this chapter that she had so anticipated of bonding with her daughter. And so, you know, it was very common at that time to use therapy as a way of ferreting out the pros, the cons, maybe the automatic thoughts behind the pros and cons,
“晋升机会，一个需要每周多工作15小时的晋升，一个她觉得是对她能力的认可的晋升。她为获得晋升感到自豪，但非常担心这会影响她所期待的与女儿建立纽带的这一篇章。所以，你知道，当时用治疗作为一种找出利弊、也许是利弊背后的自动思维的方法是非常普遍的，”
distill the relationships. But I saw in Bev that she was looking into life itself, looking for guidance in the universe, looking for some sort of connection and her relationship to who she called God to guide her. And so in the case of Bev, it occurred to me that awakened awareness would be very helpful supporting her natural capacity for awakened awareness, allowing her to
“提炼关系。但我从贝芙身上看到，她正在审视生命本身，在宇宙中寻找指导，寻找某种联系，以及她与她所称的‘神’的关系来引导她。所以对于贝芙的情况，我想到觉醒意识将非常有帮助，支持她天生的觉醒意识能力，允许她”
authorize her own whisper of a hunch, authorize her own inner knowing. And Bev within a matter of weeks took to the notion that she could trust her inner wisdom, that there was an inner spiritual compass. I didn't tell her which way the compass pointed, and I didn't offer her the proof, she started listening to her own inner wisdom. She started following her own spiritual compass and finding answers and solutions, synchronicities, pointing her on the path where in her life she could make her own choice. This was a guided, spiritually grounded decision. You say that in addition to personal practices, we can also engage in shared rich
“授权她自己那微弱的直觉，授权她自己的内在认知。贝芙在几周内就接受了她可以信任自己内在智慧的观念，即存在一个内在的精神指南针。我没有告诉她指南针指向哪个方向，我也没有给她证据，她开始倾听自己内在的智慧。她开始跟随自己的精神指南针，找到答案和解决方案，共时性，指引她走上她可以在生活中做出自己选择的道路。这是一个被引导的、精神上扎实的决定。你说除了个人修行，我们还可以参与共享的、丰富的”
and community practices. Why would engaging in these disciplines with other people make a difference, do you think, Lisa? Shankar, there's marvelous research that shows that when we pray or meditate in a community, we effectively, as an antenna, help hold presence for one another. So certainly we can pray or meditate alone and have a deep transcendent connection. And yet still when we meditate together, we hold presence for one another. We augment the intensity and the fluidity through which we connect to the transcendent. My very wonderful colleague, Dr. Andy Newberg, showed that if nine people are in a state of prayer,
“社区修行。你认为与其他人一起参与这些修行为什么会有所不同，丽莎？”“尚卡尔，有非常棒的研究表明，当我们在一个社区中祈祷或冥想时，我们实际上就像一个天线，帮助彼此保持存在。所以当然，我们可以独自祈祷或冥想，并拥有深刻的超越性联系。然而，当我们一起冥想时，我们为彼此保持存在。我们增强了我们连接到超越性事物的强度和流动性。我非常出色的同事，安迪·纽伯格博士表明，如果九个人处于祈祷状态，”
and the 10th person walks in the door and sits down, they more rapidly move into a state of transcendence as measured by the rapidity. with which their mirror neurons come up online, which means we literally hold presence for one another. We are not creating presence. We are not creating God. We are not creating consciousness. We are holding an intensified presence of the sacred into which others can move more quickly, which is very optimistic for society. So most of us turn to the language of pathology to describe the effect. effects of crises and setbacks in our lives. We talk about trauma and depression or anxiety or dysregulation. You think it's possible for us to change this framing, to think of crises and
“而第十个人走进门坐下，他们会更快地进入超越状态，这是通过他们的镜像神经元上线速度来衡量的，这意味着我们确实为彼此保持存在。我们不是在创造存在。我们不是在创造神。我们不是在创造意识。我们是在为神圣保持一种强化的存在，其他人可以更快地进入其中，这对社会来说是非常乐观的。所以我们大多数人转向病理学的语言来描述生活中危机和挫折的影响。我们谈论创伤、抑郁、焦虑或失调。你认为我们有可能改变这种框架，将危机和”
struggles as portals for growth? When we look at the data, whether it's long-term clinical course studies, epidemiological, high-risk studies, MRI studies, through multiple lenses, Shankar, we see the same laser beam of truth. which is depression potentiates spiritual growth. We still have to do the work and engage the journey. But at least two-thirds of the time, depression is not only a medical illness. It is, in fact, more of a developmental process,
“挣扎视为成长的门户吗？”“当我们查看数据时，无论是长期临床过程研究、流行病学、高风险研究、核磁共振研究，通过多种视角，尚卡尔，我们看到了同样的真理激光束。那就是抑郁症促进精神成长。我们仍然必须做工作并参与这段旅程。但至少三分之二的时间里，抑郁症不仅是一种医学疾病。它实际上更多的是一个发展过程，”
we might call a developmental depression that beckons us into a deepening and open, a growth. When we look at longitudinal twin studies, we see that there is an increasing amount of heritable, inborn contribution to spiritual awareness, starting with puberty, biological puberty, from middle to late adolescence into emerging adulthood is a surge, a biological clock from the inside out. Bring, what is my purpose? I mean ultimate purpose. What is the meaning of life? I mean sacred purpose. In fact, the most important work we do in late adolescence emerging adulthood is to engage the ultimate questions and the hunger of the heart for spiritual connection.
“我们可以称之为‘发展性抑郁症’，它召唤我们进入深化和开放、成长。当我们观察纵向双胞胎研究时，我们看到，从青春期开始，遗传的、天生的对精神意识的贡献越来越多，从青春期中期到晚期，进入新兴成年期是一个激增，一个从内到外的生物钟。‘我的目的是什么？’我的意思是终极目的。‘生命的意义是什么？’我的意思是神圣目的。事实上，我们在青春期晚期、新兴成年期所做的最重要的工作就是参与终极问题和心灵对精神联系的渴望。”
Developmental depression beckons us and is a knock at the door to spiritual awakening. Developmental depression comes back. It is not only once that we are hardwired to suffer and then grow. at midlife, we of course have cultural names, sophomore slump midlife crisis. At midlife, we again have an expansion in our spiritual capacity. And in fact, long-term clinical course studies showed us that those people who were the most spiritually engaged at midlife actually hunger and struggle the most. because as our spiritual capacity once again grows at midlife, the more spiritually engaged we are, the more we feel the existential longing. Perhaps no longer what is my meaning and purpose, but now am I living? Am I walking the walk of my meaning and purpose?
“发展性抑郁症召唤我们，是精神觉醒的敲门声。发展性抑郁症会回来。我们不仅仅是一次被硬连线去受苦然后成长。在中年，我们当然有文化名称，‘大二综合症’、‘中年危机’。在中年，我们再次拥有精神能力的扩展。事实上，长期临床过程研究向我们表明，那些在中年时期精神参与度最高的人，实际上渴望和挣扎得最多。因为随着我们的精神能力在中年再次增长，我们精神参与度越高，我们就越能感受到存在主义的渴望。也许不再是‘我的意义和目的是什么’，而是现在‘我是否在生活？我是否在践行我的意义和目的？’”
The third developmental bridge is that of the ascension to elderhood, developmental depression once again that can open into an expanded spiritual awareness. Emerging adulthood, midlife, and the ascension to elderhood are three hardwired bridges of spiritual growth, which usually kick off with existential struggle, developmental depression. This means that I'm not against medication, but medication alone is insufficient to do the profound, foundational work of spiritual growth that is a setup for a much more inspired life of dialogue. I'm wondering whether fellow clinicians and researchers worry that a focus on spirituality can take people away from biomedical interventions, cures, and treatments. And in some ways,
“第三个发展桥梁是升华为长者身份，发展性抑郁症再次可以开启扩展的精神意识。新兴成年期、中年和升华为长者身份是精神成长的三个硬连线桥梁，通常以存在主义挣扎、发展性抑郁症为开端。这意味着我并不反对药物，但仅靠药物不足以完成精神成长的深刻、基础性工作，而这正是通往更具灵感的生活对话的准备。我想知道同行临床医生和研究人员是否担心对灵性的关注会使人们远离生物医学干预、治愈和治疗。在某种程度上，”
someone comes in with depression and you say, well, the way out of your depression is to start a spiritual practice. And the person says, I'm just overwhelmed dealing with what I have right now. I can't change something that important in my life. You know, Shankar, very often people are relieved when you ask them about their spiritual life. We asked hundreds of high school students to tell us about a spiritual experience. And nearly half of our high school students said, wow, I always thought something was going on, but no one ever talked about it. In a clinical setting, people are often tremendously hopeful and relieved. and curious, that you would open the door, give name, and authorize, yes, we talk about that here.
有人因为抑郁症来求助，你说，走出抑郁的方法是开始一种精神修行。而那个人说，我光是应付眼下的生活就已经精疲力竭了。我无法改变生活中那么重要的事情。你知道吗，尚卡尔，当你询问人们的精神生活时，他们往往会感到如释重负。我们曾请数百名高中生向我们讲述一次精神体验。近一半的高中生说，哇，我一直觉得有什么东西存在，但从来没有人谈论过它。在临床环境中，人们往往会因为你打开了这扇门、给它命名并给予认可——即“是的，我们可以在这里谈论这个”——而感到无比的希望、宽慰和好奇。
Here in treatment, here at this hospital, at this clinic, in my practice, we talk about spirituality here. Now, of course, as clinicians, our goal is to keep a client-centered, patient-centered journey of spiritual exploration. So it doesn't matter what faith tradition I may be or not be. it is a client-centered process that can be open through three simple questions. Is spirituality or religion important to you? Do you sense it has something to do with what's going on right now? And would you like to explore or have support around your spiritual exploration, your spiritual life? Those are questions.
在这里治疗，在这家医院，在这家诊所，在我的执业过程中，我们谈论灵性。当然，作为临床医生，我们的目标是保持以客户为中心、以患者为中心的精神探索之旅。所以，无论我属于哪种信仰传统，或者是否拥有信仰，这都不重要。这是一个以客户为中心的过程，可以通过三个简单的问题来开启：灵性或宗教对你重要吗？你觉得它与你目前所经历的事情有关吗？你是否愿意探索或获得关于你的精神探索、你的精神生活的支持？这些就是问题所在。
And the patient in a loving alliance with good boundaries is free to say, no, you know, that's not important to me or I don't want to talk about that. Or maybe they'll come back and want to talk about another time. But the vast majority of the time, well over 70% of the time, patients say yes, yes and yes to all three. When we come back, I ask Lisa about the role of spirituality in schools. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain.
在充满关爱的联盟和良好的界限下，患者可以自由地说，不，你知道，那对我来说不重要，或者我不想谈论那个。也许他们以后会回来，想要在另一个时间谈论。但绝大多数情况下，超过70%的时间，患者对这三个问题都回答“是”。稍后回来，我将询问丽莎关于灵性在学校中的作用。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Columbia University, Lisa Miller studies the science of spirituality. She argues that we are paying short shrift to one of the most important interventions in our psychological and physical lives. Lisa, you've written and spoken about the importance of bringing spirituality
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在哥伦比亚大学，丽莎·米勒研究灵性科学。她认为，我们忽视了对我们心理和生理生活中最重要的干预措施之一。丽莎，你曾撰文并谈论过将灵性引入公共生活和我们的机构的重要性。
into public life and our institutions. Does that include our schools? Oh, yes. So right now there is a conversation that we are trying to help support between universities and K-12 schools. K-12 schools work very hard to prepare a student to enter the university to pitch them through college admissions and have them find the right home in a college. And colleges are receiving students thinking, oh my, how strung out, how without a core we're finding the culture. to have not prepared the students. So trying to bring what is effectively a spiritual crisis in the university back propagated all the way back down into kindergarten
这包括我们的学校吗？哦，是的。所以现在我们正在努力支持大学和K-12学校之间的对话。K-12学校非常努力地准备学生进入大学，帮助他们通过大学招生，并在大学里找到合适的归宿。而大学接收学生时却在想，天哪，我们发现这种文化让学生们如此紧张，如此缺乏核心。因此，试图将大学里实际上存在的精神危机，一直追溯并传播回幼儿园，
and support the whole child development, starting in kindergarten, by strengthening the spiritual core of the whole child. There's an abundant science that shows that children with a strong personal spirituality are less addicted, less depressed, protected against suicide. Children with a strong spiritual life have greater grit, optimism, greater character, more able to endure difficult times, form relationships of commitment. There is nothing in the clinical or social sciences as profoundly important to child formation
并从幼儿园开始，通过加强整个孩子的精神核心来支持全面的儿童发展。有大量的科学研究表明，拥有强大个人灵性的孩子更不容易上瘾，更不容易抑郁，并能预防自杀。拥有强大精神生活的孩子具有更强的毅力、乐观精神、更好的品格，更能忍受困难时期，并建立承诺关系。在临床或社会科学中，没有什么比强大的精神核心对儿童的塑造更为重要了。
as a strong spiritual core. So then we might ask the question, can our question? schools, can our K through 12 schools, which have come such a long way in whole child education, now go the next step to support, based on science, the spiritual core of the whole child? And the answer is yes. We conducted a three-year grant-funded study, during which time we went to very diverse schools that did support the spiritual core of the whole child. We went to Sufi schools, yeshivas, Catholic schools.
那么我们可能会问，我们的学校，我们的K-12学校，在全人教育方面已经取得了长足的进步，现在能否迈出下一步，基于科学来支持整个孩子的精神核心？答案是肯定的。我们进行了一项为期三年的资助研究，期间我们走访了许多支持孩子精神核心的多样化学校。我们去了苏菲派学校、犹太经学院、天主教会学校。
We went to Walder schools. We went to public schools in Oakland and Virginia. We went to independent schools, magnet schools. We went everywhere. It doesn't matter what geographical location, cultural niche, or religion might be present or not present in the school. No matter where we visited for three years, there is an intentional pay. pedagogical culture in spiritually supportive schools. There was nothing that landed on the desk, no curriculum, no special workbook, no practice in the classroom that was found amongst all
我们去了华德福学校。我们去了奥克兰和弗吉尼亚的公立学校。我们去了独立学校、磁石学校。我们去了各地。无论学校所在的地理位置、文化背景或宗教信仰如何，这都不重要。无论我们三年内访问了哪里，在精神支持型学校中都存在一种有意的教学文化。桌上没有任何东西，没有课程，没有特别的工作手册，课堂上也没有什么练习是所有学校共有的，
spiritually supportive schools. But what was common to all spiritually supportive schools was a deliberately designed deeply intentional, relational culture that supported the spiritual core of the child. And we were able to systematically distill the common DNA of a spiritually supportive pedagogical culture, which would apply to any school. Put that in a teachable form, and we now offer that as Awaken School's Awakened School Institute for free. Lisa, you told me about a time when you, you and your husband felt that the conversation at your social gatherings were unbearably superficial. You had dinner recently with a couple you were meeting for the first time, and the inevitable question came up,
但所有精神支持型学校的共同点是，一种经过深思熟虑、极具意图的、关系导向的文化，支持着孩子的精神核心。我们能够系统地提炼出精神支持型教学文化的共同基因，这适用于任何学校。将其转化为可教授的形式，我们现在免费提供给“觉醒学校研究所”。丽莎，你曾告诉我，你和你的丈夫感到社交聚会上的谈话极其肤浅。你最近和一对第一次见面的夫妇共进晚餐，不可避免的问题出现了，
what do you do? Paint a picture of the scene for me and tell me what happened. Shankar was at a dinner party with some very, very interesting people who I knew had lived, very adventurous, inspired lives. But once again, the weighty culture of achieving awareness beset our dinner party. What do you do? Where do you live? What does your partner do? The sort of multivariable equation through which we predict someone's outcome, their achieving awareness.
你是做什么的？请为我描绘一下当时的场景，告诉我发生了什么。尚卡尔，当时我和一些非常非常有趣的人在一起吃晚饭，我知道他们过着非常冒险、充满灵感的生活。但再一次，那种沉重的成就意识文化笼罩了我们的晚宴。你是做什么的？你住在哪里？你的伴侣是做什么的？那种多变量方程，我们通过它来预测一个人的结果，他们的成就意识。
And it seemed to me like a real missed opportunity. So this time I sat up and I took the bull by the horns and I said to some pretty prominent people, can you tell me about the most glorious day of your life? Two of them were intrigued and one was a little taken aback, but everybody played. One man said, you know, I felt very distanced from my childhood faith tradition. This gentleman was gay. He said I'd felt sort of cast out. But I was on a trip in Italy and there in the piazza.
这在我看来是一个真正错失的机会。所以这一次，我坐直了身子，当机立断，我对一些相当显赫的人说，你能告诉我你一生中最辉煌的一天吗？其中两个人很感兴趣，一个人有点吃惊，但每个人都参与了。一个人说，你知道，我感到与我童年的信仰传统非常疏远。这位先生是同性恋。他说我感到被排斥了。但我在意大利旅行时，在广场上，
I heard beautiful music from the choir, pour through the piazza. I went into the cathedral and I felt God's presence in the most abundant way I've ever felt. The next person spoke, and she said, you know, I guess I'd have to say I was out sailing. And I felt the wind in my hair and the sun in my face. We have the opportunity of our lifetime to really know each other. It takes only our choice to say, do I want to have an achieving conversation or do I really want to have an awakened conversation. Do I want this relationship to open up so that I'm not, you know, keeping up with the Joneses, but I'm walking with the Joneses. I want to know you.
我听到唱诗班美妙的音乐倾泻在广场上。我走进大教堂，感受到了我所感受过的最充盈的上帝的临在。下一个人发言，她说，你知道，我想我得说我当时在航海。我感到风吹过我的头发，阳光照在我的脸上。我们有生之年有机会真正了解彼此。这只需要我们做出选择，是进行一场关于成就的对话，还是真正进行一场觉醒的对话。我是否希望这段关系能够敞开，这样我就不是在与邻居攀比，而是在与他们同行。我想了解你。
I want to know your greatest challenges. I want to know the most beautiful moments. I want to know about the crossing of your ancestors and the birth of your children and grandchildren. I want to know the most high pixel glorious part of your life. Shankar, I think we have a lot of your life. Shankar, I think have a choice to engage one another to have relationships, which are narrowly, two-dimensional, achieving, transactional relationships, or we can open the aperture and know each other and know life itself through an awakened heart. What Lisa is challenging us to do is not easy. widening the aperture, getting beyond traditional benchmarks of achievement, deeply connecting with others, all of this can feel a bit daunting,
我想了解你最大的挑战。我想了解最美好的时刻。我想了解你祖先的跨越和你子孙的出生。我想了解你生命中最辉煌、最精彩的部分。尚卡尔，我认为我们有选择去与彼此互动，去建立那种狭隘的、二维的、交易性的成就关系，或者我们可以打开视野，通过觉醒的心去了解彼此，了解生命本身。丽莎向我们提出的挑战并不容易。拓宽视野，超越传统的成就基准，与他人深度连接，这一切都让人感到有些畏惧，
especially if you've been singularly focused on achieving an important goal in your career or personal life. We recently heard from a listener named Jean-Charl. He's been grappling with a challenge like this. Jean-Charl says that growing up, he always wanted to be an entrepreneur. What I was attracted to was, you know, the freedom of being my own. about the learning curve of being into this environment, I believe that I could actually build something that mattered. Yeah, entrepreneurship became my North Star for many years.
特别是如果你一直专注于在职业或个人生活中实现某个重要目标。我们最近收到了一位名叫让-查尔的听众的来信。他一直在应对这样的挑战。让-查尔说，他在成长过程中一直想成为一名企业家。吸引我的是，你知道，做自己的那种自由。关于进入这种环境的学习曲线，我相信我真的可以建立一些有意义的东西。是的，创业多年来一直是我的北极星。
And I spent years searching after university for the right idea, the right project. And in the meantime, I was stuck in jobs that felt meaningless. But then, when he was 30, things finally fell into place. I met a business partner with whom, we got along very well, and we built a fintech company together. And for seven years, that was my entire world. It was brutal, but it was a beautiful roller coaster. Like, I felt completely alive.
大学毕业后，我花了几年时间寻找正确的想法、正确的项目。与此同时，我被困在毫无意义的工作中。但后来，当他30岁时，事情终于水到渠成了。我遇到了一位合伙人，我们相处得很好，我们一起创办了一家金融科技公司。七年来，那是我的整个世界。那很残酷，但那是一场美丽的过山车。就像，我感到完全活着。
In 2020, Jean Chal and his partner sold their business. On paper, the sales seemed like the culmination of everything he'd ever wanted. The financial freedom it would provide me with was the dream. But the moment I let go of the business, I also let go of the thing that made me feel like me. And all of a sudden, I had lost my purpose. And I had zero plan B. I'm 42 years old now, so we sold the company five and a half years ago. And what I struggle to describe and what I find really hard to put into words is what it actually feels like to be lost in this way.
2020年，让-查尔和他的合伙人卖掉了他们的公司。在纸面上，这次出售似乎是他一直想要的一切的顶点。它将为我提供的经济自由是我的梦想。但当我放手公司的那一刻，我也放手了那个让我感到自我的东西。突然之间，我失去了目标。而且我没有任何B计划。我现在42岁了，所以我们在五年半前卖掉了公司。我难以描述，也觉得很难用语言表达的是，以这种方式迷失方向到底是什么感觉。
It's not sadness that I feel on a daily basis. more like watching my own life from behind a glass. I feel like time is passing. The things are happening around me and I'm not quite in it. I feel like I'm wasting my life, really. I just have this unsettling question that follows me every day. It's what is the point of all this? What is the point of all this? It's a question people have been grappling with for thousands of years. Various schools of thought have shaped how we answer it. A nihilist might say, there is no point. Nothing matters. A biologist would argue that our point is to survive and reproduce. An existentialist might say, the point is whatever we
我每天感受到的不是悲伤，更像是隔着玻璃看着自己的生活。我觉得时间在流逝。事情在我周围发生，而我并没有真正参与其中。我觉得我真的在浪费生命。我每天都有一个不安的问题困扰着我。那就是这一切的意义是什么？这一切的意义是什么？这是一个人们几千年来一直在纠结的问题。各种思想流派塑造了我们回答它的方式。虚无主义者可能会说，没有意义。什么都不重要。生物学家会争辩说，我们的意义是生存和繁衍。存在主义者可能会说，意义就是我们
make of it. But at Stanford University, Dave Evans argues that the question misses the point. When we come back, Dave grapples with life's big questions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When we feel stuck in life, it's often hard to see a way forward. We tell ourselves that if we just try a little bit harder, we'll figure out how to break free. At Stanford University, Dave Evans studies some of the most common traps that can lead to these feelings of stuckness. He recently joined us for two episodes of Hidden Brain.
创造出来的。但在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯认为这个问题本身就偏离了重点。稍后回来，戴夫将探讨人生的大问题。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当我们感到生活停滞不前时，往往很难看到前进的方向。我们告诉自己，只要再努力一点，就能找到突破的方法。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯研究了一些最常见的导致这种停滞感的陷阱。他最近参加了我们两期的《隐藏的大脑》节目。
They were called Designing a Life That Matters and Radical Acceptance. We received so many questions and comments in response to these two episodes that we're going to dedicate two installments of our popular segment, your questions answered, to addressing them. Dave Evans, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Shankar, it's good to be here again. Dave, before the break, we heard from a listener named Jean-Charl. Something he said really struck me.
它们被称为“设计有意义的生活”和“激进的接纳”。我们收到了许多针对这两期节目的问题和评论，因此我们将专门用两期我们广受欢迎的栏目“回答你的问题”来解决这些问题。戴夫·埃文斯，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，很高兴再次来到这里。戴夫，在休息之前，我们听到了听众让-查尔的故事。他所说的一些话真的触动了我。
He said he feels like he's watching his own life from behind a glass. So on paper, he's achieved his dream. he built a successful company and then he sold it, but now he feels like he has no purpose. What did you hear in his story? Well, he's found himself disengaged from what it felt like it means to be a human person. You know, he didn't realize what the relationship was
他说他感觉自己像是在隔着玻璃看着自己的生活。所以从纸面上看，他实现了自己的梦想。他建立了一家成功的公司，然后卖掉了它，但现在他觉得他没有目标。你在他的故事中听到了什么？嗯，他发现自己与作为一个人意味着什么的感觉脱节了。你知道，他没有意识到他的项目与他的人格之间的关系，
between his project and his personhood. And when the project was done, it relocated him in this desirable, but much more disruptive than he anticipated. place called financial independence. So he removed from his life that which almost every human being has had forever, which is the need to make a living. And so that human project and my participation in the human project is what locates me in my life. I mean, he loved the creativity and you love working with his partner and he loved making a difference to his customers. And he thought that was what the whole
当项目完成后，它将他安置在一个令人向往，但比他预期的更具破坏性的地方，即财务独立。所以他从生活中移除了几乎每个人一直以来都拥有的东西，那就是谋生的需要。因此，那个人类项目以及我对人类项目的参与，正是定位我生活的地方。我的意思是，他热爱创造力，他热爱与合伙人一起工作，他热爱为客户带来改变。他以为这就是全部，
thing was about. But all of that was located on the ground of the project of my personhood, which is making my life work and making the world work, and he took himself partly out of that, and he's not been able to refine himself. You see that many of us hold certain notions that can get in the way of the lives we want to live. One of them is to feel fulfilled. So we feel like we're achieving the full potential of our lives. We heard from listener, Sumer, who's from France, she's raising two daughters and aspires to write novels, but quickly gets overwhelmed when she tries to make progress on that goal. I'm supposed to work from home, and the reality is that I don't have time to work on my
但这一切都建立在人格项目的基础上，那就是让我的生活运转起来，让世界运转起来，而他把自己部分地从其中抽离了出来，他还没能重新定义自己。你看到我们许多人持有某些观念，这些观念可能会阻碍我们想要过的生活。其中之一就是感到满足。所以我们觉得我们正在实现我们生活的全部潜力。我们听到了来自法国的听众苏玛的来信，她抚养着两个女儿，渴望写小说，但当她试图在那个目标上取得进展时，很快就会感到不知所措。我应该在家工作，但现实是我没有时间去写我的
stories. I keep telling myself that I'm not making any money. My husband is the only one working, and I'm not contributing financially for my family. Then I start looking for a job, then I stop and think of all the consequences if I go back to work, how our life would be, and I just feel stuck. I think that if I publish only one novel, I would be happy, but then I think there is no way I'm going to help financially my family with only one novel, and then I'm stuck again. I feel like I have everything. I have a wonderful husband. I love him very much. I have two. wonderful, beautiful daughters. I love them more than my life. We are healthy. We are doing great. We live in a great apartment. We live in a great city in France. I feel like I have everything I need, but I can't find a meaning to my life. I don't know what to do with my life. And it's very hard sometimes.
故事。我一直告诉自己，我没有赚到任何钱。我丈夫是唯一工作的人，我没有为家庭做出经济贡献。然后我开始找工作，然后我又停下来思考如果我回去工作会产生的所有后果，我们的生活会变成什么样，我就感到被困住了。我想如果我只出版一部小说，我会很高兴，但后来我想，仅凭一部小说我不可能在经济上帮助我的家庭，然后我又被困住了。我觉得我拥有一切。我有一个很棒的丈夫。我非常爱他。我有两个很棒、漂亮的女儿。我爱她们胜过我的生命。我们很健康。我们做得很好。我们住在一间很棒的公寓里。我们住在法国一个很棒的城市。我觉得我拥有我需要的一切，但我找不到生活的意义。我不知道该拿我的生活怎么办。有时这真的很难。
So, Dave, I feel like Sumaa is trying to take on multiple challenges at once. She wants to write a novel, which is a big goal in itself. But then she layers on the question of whether a single novel will be enough to move the needle financially for her family. That adds more pressure. And then she adds on another layer, which is the layer of finding meaning, which makes a challenge feel even more daunting. How do you think Sumaa can make her goals more manageable? Well, she's got a couple of things going on at the same time, and very sympathetic. She's in a situation we actually call having what we call an anchor problem.
所以，戴夫，我觉得苏玛试图同时承担多项挑战。她想写一部小说，这本身就是一个大目标。但随后她又加上了“一部小说是否足以在经济上为她的家庭带来改变”的问题。这增加了更多的压力。然后她又加上了另一层，即寻找意义的层面，这使得挑战感觉更加艰巨。你认为苏玛怎样才能让她的目标更容易管理？嗯，她同时在处理几件事，我很同情她。她处于一种我们称之为“锚点问题”的情况。
She's anchored to a problem she can't seem to get loose from. So if that's the case, her anchor problem is, I want to have an experience of meaning making, which I've attached to writing a novel, and I want to make enough money to feel like I'm contributing at a level that satisfies my preferences or frankly my ego. Those are not good or bad things. they're just true. What's really true about Sumia's life, what's really true about their finances, and those constraints will define what the problem space really is. If she needs money, I would agree with her. One novel is probably not the way to get that. So let's go get a job and then maybe you can write
她被一个似乎无法摆脱的问题锚定了。所以如果是这样的话，她的锚点问题是：我想要一种意义创造的体验，我把它附加到了写小说上，而且我想赚足够的钱，让我觉得我在贡献，达到满足我偏好或坦率地说是我的自尊的水平。这些不是好坏之分，它们只是事实。关于苏玛的生活，关于他们的财务状况，什么是真正真实的，这些限制将定义问题空间到底是什么。如果她需要钱，我会同意她的看法。一部小说可能不是实现这一目标的方法。所以让我们去找份工作，然后也许你可以写
short stories on the side, but you've got to do some radical acceptance about that. If your husband's fine with supporting you, are you willing to do the hard thing called accepting a gift? So it's all about acceptance and living in reality. So both Sumaya and Jean-Sharal, both of them get at the big thorny question that many of us grapple with, which is what is the meaning of life? You argue that asking big existential questions like this is not always helpful. Why not, Dave? Well, particularly in the form of what is the meaning of my life, which sounds like there's
短篇小说作为副业，但你必须对此进行一些激进的接纳。如果你的丈夫乐意支持你，你愿意做那件被称为“接受礼物”的困难事情吗？所以这一切都是关于接纳和活在现实中。因此，苏玛和让-查尔都触及了我们许多人都在纠结的那个棘手的大问题，那就是生命的意义是什么？你认为提出这样的大存在主义问题并不总是有帮助。为什么不呢，戴夫？嗯，特别是在“我生命的意义是什么”这种形式下，听起来好像存在着
an answer. You know, and Bill, my partner and I are shortest definition of the human person, anthropologically is that a person is a becoming. We are all an unfolding embodied spiritual intelligence, a very complicated being called a human person. And we're always growing into our future selves. So if the future me isn't here yet, how could my present me ever come up with one answer that is reliable for the rest of my life? So we're saying, how can I design more meaning in the life that I'm in now. So don't get stuck on trying to come up with the ultimate answer. And in both cases here, by the way, both John Charles and Sumaya have a point of view about what meaning has to be.
一个答案。你知道，比尔和我的合伙人，我们对人类最简短的定义，从人类学角度来说，就是人是一个“正在成为”的过程。我们都是一个正在展开的、具身化的精神智能，一个被称为人类的复杂存在。我们总是在成长为未来的自己。所以，如果未来的我还没有到来，现在的我怎么可能得出一个对我余生都可靠的答案呢？所以我们说，我该如何在当下的生活中设计出更多的意义。因此，不要执着于寻找终极答案。顺便说一下，在这里的两个案例中，约翰·查尔斯和苏玛雅对于“意义必须是什么”都有自己的观点。
In John Charles' case, there's an unspoken assumption about his relationship with the work world that he didn't realize. And for Summa, it's about money and meaning making. And so they've got little rules buried in their questions that are forcing them into a stuck place because they want it on their terms, frankly, and those terms aren't working. And so if we can reset to reality, here's the situation you're actually in that gives you some freedom to go forward to the place you can go, which may not be the place you want to go, but it is the place you can go. Another belief that you say can get in the way of change is the need to have impact. Now, that could be impact on the people around us, impact via our work, even an impact on the world as a whole.
在约翰·查尔斯的案例中，他对自己与工作世界的关系有一个未曾察觉的隐含假设。而对于苏玛雅来说，这关乎金钱与意义的创造。所以，他们的问题中埋藏着一些小规则，这些规则迫使他们陷入困境，因为坦率地说，他们想按自己的条件行事，而这些条件行不通。所以，如果我们能重置到现实中——这就是你实际所处的境地——这会给你一些自由，让你走向你能去的地方，那可能不是你想去的地方，但却是你能去的地方。你提到的另一个阻碍改变的信念是“需要产生影响”。这可能是对周围人的影响，通过工作产生的影响，甚至是作为一个整体对世界的影响。
Now, many of us strive to have that impact, but feel that our efforts are largely unsuccessful. Here's a note from listener, Amy. When I was 12 years old, I declared on paper that I was going to spend the rest of my life saving animals. And that's what I did. At 16, I became a volunteer in animal shelter, worked my way up through the years to, you know, animal care tech, to shelter, and then a program coordinator through a couple different animal shelters. And then one day it just hit me that nothing I did really mattered. Nobody really cared.
现在，我们许多人努力去产生那种影响，但觉得我们的努力大多是不成功的。这是听众艾米发来的一条信息：当我12岁时，我在纸上宣布我余生都要致力于拯救动物。我确实也这么做了。16岁时，我成为了一名动物收容所的志愿者，多年来我一步步晋升，你知道，从动物护理技术员到收容所管理，再到几家不同动物收容所的项目协调员。然后有一天，我突然意识到，我所做的一切其实毫无意义。根本没人真正在乎。
I felt like a waste of space there, a waste of money for the organization, honestly. And so I left. And now I avoid taking care of animals at all costs. It's insane. I don't know who I am anymore. So I can certainly feel Amy's pain here, Dave. Oh, boy, yeah. Talk about how our craving for impact shapes our choices
我感觉自己在那儿就是浪费空间，老实说，对组织来说也是浪费钱。所以我离开了。现在我竭尽全力避免照顾动物。这太疯狂了。我不知道自己是谁了。戴夫，我当然能感受到艾米的痛苦。哦，天哪，是的。谈谈我们对影响力的渴望是如何塑造我们的选择
and our perceptions of failure and success. So impact is a very worthwhile thing to pursue. We need a bunch of positive impact. So, you know, the problem is when you put all of your meaning-making eggs, and in Amy's case, all your identity eggs, in the impact basket, you're at terrific risk. Two ways. Number one, most of the time, even if you do everything right, your attempted impact doesn't work. I mean, it literally doesn't work. You try to save the animal and it dies anyway. Or even if it does work,
以及我们对失败和成功的看法。所以，影响力是一件非常值得追求的事情。我们需要大量的积极影响。所以，问题在于当你把所有的意义创造，在艾米的案例中，把你所有的身份认同，都放在“影响力”这个篮子里时，你就处于巨大的风险之中。有两个原因：第一，大多数时候，即使你做对了一切，你试图产生的影响也不会奏效。我是说，它真的没用。你试图拯救动物，但它还是死了。或者即使它奏效了，
it doesn't last very long in the world, or you succeed, and then frankly, the feeling of it doesn't last very long. The half-life on an impact, which is an objective fact. It's just transaction, it's not a living thing. Doesn't go on and on and on. We worked with the U.S. Olympic Committee because there's nothing as exciting as ascending the Olympic platform or as terrifying as descending it. On the other side of being the best in the world is like, now what? So this is a fundamental human problem. Amy's got it in spades. So the issue here is recognizing number one that I need more than just impact. making, more than just changing the world as a source of what makes my life worthwhile.
它在世界上持续的时间并不长，或者你成功了，但坦率地说，那种感觉持续的时间也不长。影响力的半衰期是一个客观事实。它只是一种交易，不是一个活物。它不会没完没了地持续下去。我们曾与美国奥委会合作，因为没有什么比登上奥运领奖台更令人兴奋，也没有什么比走下领奖台更令人恐惧的了。在成为世界第一之后，接下来该做什么？所以这是一个基本的人类问题。艾米对此深有体会。所以这里的问题在于，首先要认识到我需要的不仅仅是影响力，不仅仅是把改变世界作为我生命价值的来源。
If that's the only thing I've got going, I'm really at risk. And number two, on that aspect of my life that's pointed toward impact making, recognizing you have no power whatsoever over the outcome creating the result you want. All you can control is your participation. She was a very successful animal defender, but she wrote a rule for herself. that unless I save this many animals or, you know, the world changes its mind, or the people around me get it the way I get it, none of which she has any power of it at all, by the way.
如果这是我唯一拥有的东西，我真的处于危险之中。第二，在生活中指向产生影响的那一方面，要认识到你对创造你想要的结果没有任何权力。你唯一能控制的就是你的参与。她是一位非常成功的动物保护者，但她为自己写下了一条规则：除非我拯救了这么多动物，或者，你知道，世界改变了主意，或者周围的人像我一样理解这件事——顺便说一下，这些她都完全无法控制。
Unless those things become true, all my efforts were a waste of time. And that's a powerful rule that she has written. And frankly, it's untrue and she can rewrite it. When we come back, inflection points, how moments when the ground collapses beneath us can help us to grow in remarkable ways. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us dream of making an impact on the world.
除非这些事情成为现实，否则我所有的努力都是浪费时间。这是一条她写下的强有力的规则。坦率地说，这是不真实的，她可以重写它。当我们回来时，我们将讨论转折点，即当脚下的地面崩塌时，这些时刻如何能以非凡的方式帮助我们成长。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们许多人梦想着对世界产生影响。
But this aspiration doesn't always bring happiness. And when we see we're not making an impact, we can start to feel trapped in a job or a relationship. At Stanford University, Dave Evans studies how we can design our lives in ways that can be more satisfying and enduringly successful. So let me turn again to listener questions and stories, we heard from a listener named Brian. He was the city manager of a community north of Detroit.
但这种抱负并不总是带来幸福。当我们看到自己没有产生影响时，我们可能会开始感到被困在某份工作或某种关系中。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯研究我们如何以更令人满意和持久成功的方式设计我们的生活。那么，让我再次转向听众的问题和故事，我们听到了来自听众布莱恩的消息。他是底特律北部一个社区的城市经理。
On paper, he had achieved a lot of success. He had leadership, influence, stability, but inside, he says he felt trapped. Every morning on my drive to City Hall, I passed under the I-75 overpass and told myself the same thing. I have to get out of this job. I must change my life. But I was successful and bored. restless, toxic, profoundly stuck. Then my life spiraled even further downward. Divorce, drinking,
在纸面上，他取得了很大的成功。他拥有领导力、影响力、稳定性，但内心深处，他说他感到被困住了。每天早上开车去市政厅的路上，我都会经过I-75立交桥，并对自己说同样的话：我必须离开这份工作。我必须改变我的生活。但我很成功，也很无聊。焦躁不安、有毒、深陷困境。然后我的生活进一步螺旋式下降。离婚、酗酒、
sleeping alone on the floor with nothing, all while showing up at the office, poised, professional, and well-spoken, but not very sharp. Just when I thought I hit bottom, the trap door opened, and further I went. The FBI had wired a road construction contractor who had befriended me. We got drunk during the Christmas season, and he took me out to his truck to discuss business. He handed me $1,000 money, money I accepted, and asked me if I was going to give him the new road contract. Shortly thereafter, I pled guilty to bribery. I was sentenced to 30 months in federal prison. Hello, hell.
独自睡在地板上，一无所有，同时还要在办公室表现得从容、专业、谈吐得体，但其实并不敏锐。就在我以为我触底时，活板门打开了，我掉得更深了。联邦调查局给一位与我交好的道路施工承包商装了窃听器。圣诞节期间我们喝醉了，他带我到他的卡车里讨论生意。他给了我1000美元——我接受了这笔钱——并问我是否会把新的道路合同给他。此后不久，我承认了贿赂罪。我被判处30个月联邦监禁。你好，地狱。
What should have been the worst chapter of my life became an unexpected reset. Prison stripped away my title, ego, and identity. but it also forced me to rebuild from the ground up one step at a time. The irony is that the very thing I feared most became the catalyst for rebirth. Prison gave me the disruption I never could have chosen for myself, but desperately needed. It forced me to confront how deeply stuck I had been long before my conviction. So as Brian experienced sometimes life forces us to change, we also heard from a listener named Audrey, who enjoyed a successful career in IT until she was laid off in 2024.
本应是我生命中最糟糕的篇章，却成了一次意想不到的重置。监狱剥夺了我的头衔、自我和身份，但也迫使我一步一个脚印地从零开始重建。讽刺的是，我最害怕的事情成了重生的催化剂。监狱给了我我永远无法为自己选择，但却迫切需要的破坏。它迫使我面对在定罪前很久我就已经陷入了多深的困境。正如布莱恩所经历的那样，有时生活迫使我们改变。我们还听到了听众奥黛丽的故事，她在IT行业拥有成功的职业生涯，直到2024年被裁员。
And it gave me the opportunity to reassess. I took a step back and was reminded by one of my daughters that a while back I considered being a birth dula, and that seemed like such a radical departure from a director of IT. I couldn't even imagine how that might happen. But I began looking into it and have sense over the past year, built a wonderful new career as a birth dula, childbirth educator, and lactation consultant, supporting new moms who are having babies.
这给了我重新评估的机会。我退后一步，我的一位女儿提醒我，前段时间我曾考虑过成为一名导乐（分娩陪护），这看起来与IT总监的身份截然不同。我甚至无法想象这怎么可能发生。但我开始研究它，在过去的一年里，我建立了一个很棒的新职业，成为了一名导乐、分娩教育家和哺乳顾问，支持那些正在生孩子的新妈妈们。
And I feel like with the birth of the first few babies that I've helped, I've done more good for the world than I did in 25 years in IT. So that's another amazing story, Dave. And I'm so struck by something that both Brian and Audrey said, that they would never have made the choices they made if they had to make them on their own. It's only because one door closed that they could start to think about a new one. As someone who studied how we can intentionally design our lives, I'm wondering how these stories land for you.
我觉得随着我帮助出生的前几个婴儿，我所做的善事比我在IT行业25年里做的还要多。所以这是另一个了不起的故事，戴夫。布莱恩和奥黛丽所说的话让我深受触动，如果他们必须自己做决定，他们永远不会做出那样的选择。只有因为一扇门关上了，他们才能开始考虑另一扇门。作为一名研究我们如何有意识地设计生活的人，我想知道这些故事对你有什么启发。
Well, you know, the work the Bill and I do has put us in the place of hearing lots of people's stories, lots of people like Brian and Audrey. And what it turns out is most people's lives, if you look back from 60 or 70 or 80, they'll tell you there's a handful of inflection points where everything changed. And those inflection points are the most meaningful transitions in their lives. Very often they know the exact minute those inflection points occurred. And most of them are outside in, not inside out. It's not when Audrey, you know, decided, I think I've done as much for IT as I can,
嗯，你知道，比尔和我的工作让我们有机会听到很多人的故事，很多像布莱恩和奥黛丽这样的人。事实证明，大多数人的生活，如果你从60岁、70岁或80岁回望，他们会告诉你，有几个转折点改变了一切。而这些转折点是他们生命中最有意义的转变。通常他们知道这些转折点发生的具体时间。而且大多数都是“由外而内”的，而不是“由内而外”的。并不是当奥黛丽决定，“我想我在IT领域已经尽力了，
and now I'm going to start living into my dula self. That would be inside out. That would be, and I got laid off. And holy cow, now what do I do? And so it turns out for most people, not every by any means, but many important changes occur outside in. And so in both Brian and Audrey's cases, in one case prison and one case the layoff, outside in showed up with such strength that it gave them permission to finally think differently about themselves. Maybe I could do this differently. So what, you know, what Audrey is doing is is a perfect example of what we say all the time.
现在我要开始活出我的导乐自我了。”那将是“由内而外”。那是，“我被裁员了。天哪，现在我该怎么办？”所以事实证明，对大多数人来说——绝非全部——但许多重要的变化都是“由外而内”发生的。因此，在布莱恩和奥黛丽的案例中，一个是监狱，一个是裁员，“由外而内”以如此强大的力量出现，以至于他们终于有权以不同的方式思考自己。也许我可以换种方式做这件事。所以，你知道，奥黛丽正在做的事情是我们一直所说的完美例子。
all of us contain far more aliveness, more personhood than one lifetime permits you to live out. There's more than one of you in there. She had fallen for her director of IT self. In fact, I think she actually used the phrase, I couldn't imagine a way to live into that being of Ruth Dula. You know, our colleague at Harvard, Dan Gilbert, talks about that question. When somebody tells you, I just can't imagine, most of the time what that tells you is not how, likely that thing is, it tells you that that person's imagination is not reaching far enough. So what we do, a lot of our work is trying to reframe a person's perception of themselves.
我们每个人所包含的生命力、人格，远比一生所能活出的要多。你内心不止有一个你。她曾沉迷于她“IT总监”的自我。事实上，我想她确实用了这样的话：“我无法想象如何活出导乐那个存在。”你知道，我们在哈佛的同事丹·吉尔伯特谈到了那个问题。当有人告诉你“我无法想象”时，大多数时候这告诉你的不是那件事有多大可能，而是告诉你的那个人的想象力不够远。所以我们所做的，我们很多工作是试图重构一个人对自己的认知。
You are bigger than one lifetime worth of a person. You don't have to be just one of you. You could actually decide to live into another version of you. I can't promise you you can make as much money as a birth duel as you could as the director of IT. I can't change the market forces for you. but you can actually be in charge of your life. You know, I'm struck that some of the stories we've heard are people who feel like they're stuck in dead-end jobs, things are not going well, and they're trying to get themselves unstuck.
你比一生所能活出的一个人要大得多。你不必只有一个你。你实际上可以决定活出另一个版本的你。我不能保证你作为导乐能赚到像IT总监那样多的钱。我无法为你改变市场力量，但你实际上可以掌控你的生活。你知道，让我印象深刻的是，我们听到的一些故事是那些觉得被困在死胡同工作中的人，事情进展不顺，他们正试图让自己摆脱困境。
But we're also hearing stories from people who say, you know, I'm super successful, but I'm not doing what I really should be doing, and I also feel stuck. And in some ways, it's a more subtle form of stuckness, which is its success that is causing you to feel stuck, as opposed to failure. There's a big difference between proving to yourself that you can achieve a certain outcome and wanting to live there and do that.
但我们也听到了来自那些说“你知道，我非常成功，但我没有做我真正应该做的事情，我也感到被困住了”的人的故事。在某种程度上，这是一种更微妙的困境，即是成功导致了你的困境，而不是失败。向自己证明你能实现某种结果，与想要住在那里并做那件事之间有很大的区别。
When I was 18 and I was a senior in high school, I had always thought since sixth grade that I should be the president of the student body. For some reason, I decided that's who I am. And so when I was a senior, I ran for president because I wanted to win president. Now, my dear friend Kent, who really wanted to be president of the school, he spent his whole summer interviewing every high school president in all of Southern California. He talked to all the principals. He was looking at where is education going? What reforms could we bring to our high school? He had this huge platform of work and policies that he was going to lead to actually make the school a better school.
当我18岁读高三时，我从六年级起就一直认为我应该成为学生会主席。出于某种原因，我决定那就是我。所以当我读高三时，我竞选主席，因为我想赢得主席职位。现在，我亲爱的朋友肯特，他真的很想成为学校主席，他整个夏天都在采访南加州所有的学生会主席。他与所有的校长交谈。他在观察教育的发展方向。我们可以为我们的高中带来什么改革？他有一个巨大的工作和政策平台，他将领导这些工作，使学校真正成为一所更好的学校。
I just wanted to be elected. I just wanted to have the experience of all my peers going, Dave's our favorite guy. You know, and so I ran and thankfully Kent beat me with a stick. I lost miserably. And I walked away from that going, shoot, thank God. You know, because I don't want to do this work. And there's a huge difference between I really want to be elected. I want to become CEO.
我只是想当选。我只是想体验一下我所有的同龄人都说“戴夫是我们最喜欢的人”。你知道，所以我参加了竞选，谢天谢地，肯特以压倒性优势击败了我。我走开时心想，呼，谢天谢地。你知道，因为我不想做这份工作。而且“我真的很想当选”和“我想成为首席执行官”之间有巨大的区别。
I want to make a million dollars. I want to have a bestselling book. I want to have, I want to achieve something. I want to achieve, you know, a ribbon or a prize of some kind. And then, oh, now I am the CEO and I have this huge job and it's a ton of work and everybody's on me all day long and like, oh, wow. We talk about designing your life, not designing your goal. Life isn't a goal. Life is a lived experience.
我想赚一百万美元。我想写一本畅销书。我想拥有，我想实现什么。我想实现，你知道，某种丝带或奖项。然后，哦，现在我是首席执行官了，我有这份巨大的工作，工作量巨大，每个人整天都在找我，就像，哦，哇。我们谈论的是设计你的生活，而不是设计你的目标。生活不是一个目标。生活是一种活生生的体验。
So many of these questions often come to the floor in midlife. People are often taking stock of where they are, where they want to go. Here's a story from listener, Olga. I am a woman in my 40s and in my 20s I had this drive and plan. I was going to be an attorney. I had a whole career path planned out for myself. And when I came out of law school and I wasn't able to secure position, I ended up just letting that dream die.
许多这些问题通常在人到中年时浮出水面。人们经常盘点自己所处的位置，以及他们想去的地方。这是来自听众奥尔加的故事：我是一位40多岁的女性，在20多岁时，我有这种动力和计划。我打算成为一名律师。我为自己规划了整个职业道路。当我从法学院毕业时，我没能获得职位，我最终只是让那个梦想破灭了。
And it stopped me from making any plans. And I find myself kind of drifting along with my husband's plans or my parents' plans or whoever else has an idea for, where their life is going to go. I have a job and I'm working, but I don't feel like my life is designed. I'm wondering, do you have any advice for somebody who is facing kind of a midlife without a design in plan, without an idea of how to design your life moving forward on best steps to take? So Dave, you and I talked a bit in our Hidden Brain Plus conversation about using design thinking in different stages of life.
这阻止了我制定任何计划。我发现自己有点随波逐流，跟着我丈夫的计划、我父母的计划，或者任何其他人对他们生活走向的想法走。我有工作，我也在工作，但我觉得我的生活没有被设计过。我想知道，对于那些面临中年危机却没有任何设计计划，或者不知道如何设计未来生活的人，你有什么建议吗？戴夫，你和我曾在我们的《隐藏的大脑Plus》对话中谈到在人生的不同阶段使用设计思维。
That conversation was called seasons of meaning for anyone who'd like to go back and hear it. Talk if you were, Dave, about the particular design challenges we face when we're at the midpoint of life and how you would advise Olga at the stage that she's in right now. So Olga has a real problem
那次对话被称为“意义的季节”，任何想回去听的人都可以去听。戴夫，如果你愿意，谈谈我们在人生中点面临的特殊设计挑战，以及你会如何建议处于目前阶段的奥尔加。所以奥尔加有一个真正的问题
and I've encountered it many times. It's not that uncommon. So she had something very specific in mind and it failed. Didn't work out. She actually did everything right. She went to a law school. She was on the plan.
我遇到过很多次。这并不罕见。所以她心里有非常具体的目标，但失败了。没成功。她其实做对了一切。她上了法学院。她按计划行事。
that she had conceived in her 20s and had energy for, and it didn't work out. And when it didn't work out, she had no plan B in mind. She probably didn't have an idea of what the not a successful lawyer Olga even could be. And what would design thinking recommend that Olga do? Olga needs something that she hasn't had in a long time, an interest in something she cares about. And so if I were sitting down with Olga in office hours, I'd say, Olga, look, You've been doing other people's things for a long, long, long time. It has worked out okay.
那是她在20多岁时构想出来的，并且有精力去投入，但结果并不如意。当事情没成时，她没有备选方案。她可能根本不知道，如果不做一名成功的律师，奥尔加还能成为什么样的人。设计思维会建议奥尔加做什么呢？奥尔加需要一些她很久没有的东西，即对她真正在意的事物产生兴趣。所以，如果我在办公时间与奥尔加坐下来谈，我会说：“奥尔加，你看，你已经为别人的事情忙碌了太久太久。这虽然还过得去。”
It's not horrible, but it's not very life-giving. And now, finally, your sake is saying, hey, we think it's our turn, but we have no idea what to do with it. So great. That's a great project. Let's go curate your curiosity. Tell me what you're interested in. Tell me what books you read. I would work with her to find anything at all that she cares about.
“这并不糟糕，但也没什么生命力。现在，终于，你的内心在说，嘿，我觉得该轮到我们了，但我们不知道该怎么办。太好了。这是一个很棒的项目。让我们去整理你的好奇心吧。告诉我你对什么感兴趣。告诉我你读过什么书。”我会和她一起寻找任何她真正在意的东西。
And let's grab one or two of those things and start reading version. down into those things. Let's write those authors and find their contact on LinkedIn. Let's get into the conversation. Let's see who else in your town cares about that and go buy them a cup of coffee. We'll start working on Olga caring about something she cares about. It's totally doable, but she's got a long sleep to awaken from. When we come back, listeners share their stories of how they've gotten unstuck. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedan. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Stanford University, Dave Evans studies design thinking.
让我们抓住其中一两件事，开始深入研究。让我们给那些作者写信，在领英上找到他们的联系方式。让我们加入对话。看看你所在的城市里还有谁关心这些，去请他们喝杯咖啡。我们将开始致力于让奥尔加去关心她在意的事情。这完全做得到，但她需要从长久的沉睡中醒来。稍后回来，听众们将分享他们如何走出困境的故事。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在斯坦福大学，戴夫·埃文斯研究设计思维。
He says that this approach can help us lead more meaningful lives. Along with Bill Burnett, he is the author of How to Live a Meaningful Life, using design thinking to unlock purpose, joy, and flow every day. Today, he's answering listener questions and comments about his work. Dave, one of the suggestions you make is to remain fully engaged, but calmly detached with any project. Unpack this idea for me. What does it mean to be fully engaged but calmly detached?
他说，这种方法可以帮助我们过上更有意义的生活。他与比尔·伯内特合著了《如何过上有意义的生活：利用设计思维每天解锁目标、快乐和心流》。今天，他将回答听众关于他工作的提问和评论。戴夫，你提出的建议之一是：在任何项目中都要保持充分投入，但又要保持冷静的超脱。请为我解读这个想法。什么是“充分投入但冷静超脱”？
So fully engaged means you're showing up. You're fully participating in what you're doing at the time. It really means you're entering the flow state, which we could talk more about. But what that means is my attention, my energy, my experience of myself and my surroundings is all focused on what's actually happening right now. I'm not talking to Shankar and thinking about what I'm going to cook. for dinner or our friend Catherine who's visiting. I hope she's having a good time. That's not being engaged. That's being distracted. So engagement means my full attention in the present
充分投入意味着你身在其中。你正在全身心地参与你当时所做的事情。这实际上意味着你进入了心流状态，我们可以对此多谈谈。但这意味着我的注意力、我的精力、我对自我和周围环境的体验，都集中在当下正在发生的事情上。我不是在和香卡交谈时，还在想晚餐要做什么，或者想念正在拜访我们的朋友凯瑟琳。我希望她玩得开心。那不是投入，那是分心。所以投入意味着我的全部注意力都在当下。
moment. Detachment means, and that thing I'm doing, I'm doing for its own sake, freely, not worrying about the outcome and its results. So gosh, I really hope this Q&A session goes, well, it's great. This Shankar call back and ask me. Okay, that's all worrying about the outcome. So I want to be fully engaged. So I'm really thinking about your listener questions. I want to be detached, and those two things together allow me to be more fully alive in the moment, and that full aliveness allows me to feel more like a person. And feeling more like a person is pretty meaningful. So staying in the moment and remaining engaged is a worthy goal, but it can be tricky to
时刻。超脱意味着，我所做的这件事，是为了它本身而做，自由自在，不担心结果。所以，天哪，我真希望这次问答环节顺利，这太棒了。香卡回电问我。好吧，那都是在担心结果。所以我想要充分投入。所以我真的在思考听众的问题。我想要超脱，这两者结合在一起，让我能在当下活得更充分，而这种充分的生命力让我感觉更像一个人。而感觉更像一个人是非常有意义的。所以保持在当下并保持投入是一个值得追求的目标，但要长期维持这一点可能很棘手。
maintain that over time. A listener named Kaushael says his life seems great on paper. Here he is. I'm someone who is from the hills of Sri Lanka. I got a great scholarship to go to one of the best schools in the world. I then moved to London, married a love of my life. I have a gorgeous little baby who's 13 months old. And I do incredible work as a consultant in financial services.
一位名叫考沙尔的听众说，他的生活在纸面上看起来很完美。他在这里。我来自斯里兰卡的山区。我获得了一份很棒的奖学金，去了世界上最好的学校之一。后来我搬到了伦敦，娶了我的挚爱。我有一个13个月大的可爱宝宝。我在金融服务领域做着令人难以置信的咨询工作。
I have a phenomenal team. I have mentors. I have opportunity. So it's all there, but I feel stuck. What landed for me was the distinction between being in the moment to do better at what you're doing and being in the moment just because I was raised a Buddhist, so mindfulness, presence, that's all been taught my whole life. But where I struggle with is how do you actually keep staying in the moment?
我有一个出色的团队。我有导师。我有机会。所以一切都有了，但我感到被困住了。对我来说，真正触动我的是“为了把事情做得更好而活在当下”与“仅仅因为活在当下”之间的区别。我是作为佛教徒长大的，所以正念、临在，这些我从小就被教导。但我挣扎的地方在于，你如何真正持续地活在当下？
How do you keep making the best of the moment? Is it a habit? Is it something else? I just would love some thoughts on that. So David sounds like Kaushal is doing many of the things that you and others would recommend. The question is how to maintain these. practices, not just when you're, you know, making time for meditation, but as you're going about your daily life, any thoughts on that particular challenge? Yes, I'm smiling because I'm very impressed. Kalshaw has really thoughtfully observed himself and asked an interesting question. He's
你如何不断地从当下中获得最大收益？这是一种习惯吗？还是别的什么？我很想听听对此的想法。戴夫，听起来考沙尔正在做许多你和其他人推荐的事情。问题是如何维持这些练习，不仅仅是在你留出时间冥想时，而是在你的日常生活中，对此有什么想法吗？是的，我在微笑，因为我印象非常深刻。考沙尔非常深思熟虑地观察了自己，并提出了一个有趣的问题。他
catching himself realizing, oh my goodness, moment by moment, I notice, am I in this moment and I'm loving it because I'm doing it well, or am I enjoying it, am I loving it because it's intrinsically valuable to me, and I love this thing. So what he has pointed out is we recently had this conversation with Bob Waldinger at Harvard, the last project leader of the longest running behavioral study of mankind, the Harvard Adult Study, reminded us that if you live all through extrinsic motivations, outside in, you know, curing cancer, making the money, making partner, whether it's a selfish
捕捉到了自己，意识到，天哪，时刻都在发生，我注意到，我是在当下并热爱它，因为我做得很好，还是我在享受它，我热爱它是因为它对我本身就有价值，我热爱这件事。所以他指出的这一点，我们最近和哈佛大学的鲍勃·沃尔丁格进行过交流，他是人类历史上运行时间最长的行为研究——哈佛成人研究的最后一位项目负责人，他提醒我们，如果你完全靠外在动机生活，由外而内，你知道，治愈癌症、赚大钱、成为合伙人，无论这是一个自私的
or a self-less goal, it's still outside in. And you lose track of the intrinsic motivators of love, compassion, joy, things for their own intrinsic sake. And you do too much extrinsic and too little intrinsic. You start losing over time the capacity to even notice and catch the signals of the experience of the intrinsic experience. So what Kalshaw is catching himself in is Oh, my goodness. I'm mostly extrinsically motivated. So the first thing is be forgiving. If I'm a becoming, I'm going to get better tomorrow, which means by tomorrow, I will look back and say, I was worse today.
还是无私的目标，它仍然是“由外而内”。你会失去对爱、同情、快乐这些内在动机的追踪，这些事情本身就具有内在价值。如果你做得太多外在的，太少内在的，随着时间的推移，你开始失去感知和捕捉内在体验信号的能力。所以考沙尔捕捉到的是：天哪，我主要是受外在驱动的。所以第一件事是宽容。如果我是一个“正在成长的人”，我明天会做得更好，这意味着到明天，我会回顾并说，我今天做得不够好。
That's okay. You don't have to boil the ocean in one step. One step at a time, you're becoming. We're going to get there. It starts with the realization. He's actually in a very good place. Dave, we heard from some listeners who said that their ability to redesign their lives is limited. three years ago, listener Miguel moved with his family to Singapore.
没关系。你不需要一步就煮沸大海。一步一个脚印，你正在成长。我们会到达那里的。这始于这种觉悟。他实际上处于一个非常好的位置。戴夫，我们听到一些听众说，他们重塑生活的能力是有限的。三年前，听众米格尔和家人搬到了新加坡。
His wife landed an exciting new job, and they jumped at the chance for their two young kids to live abroad. But Miguel says it hasn't been easy. I've had to also make a really big adjustment as far as how I spend my time, how I view career, and I've also had to navigate some loss. My mom had died a few months ago due to complications from children. cancer, which really sparked a lot of questions about just purposefulness and life and meaning.
他的妻子找到了一份令人兴奋的新工作，他们抓住了让两个年幼的孩子在国外生活的机会。但米格尔说，这并不容易。我不得不做出非常大的调整，关于我如何度过时间，我如何看待职业生涯，而且我还不得不应对一些损失。我妈妈几个月前因儿童癌症并发症去世了，这确实引发了很多关于人生目的和意义的问题。
And these are questions that I myself had asked when I also got sick during the pandemic, also with cancer, which I have since survived. And I really appreciate the designing of our own lives, the concept of that. And I'm just wanting to figure out what's a way I can honor that process without having it be so self-centered. Having two really young kids and a partner who depends on me, I would like to make sure that even as I interrogate my own life and think about how to make responsible choices and restart career, that I don't do so without compromising my responsibility to my partner and to my kids. So if there's any question there, I suppose it's what can I do to balance designing my life and taking this fresh opportunity for any start while not neglecting our responsibilities as a partner and as a parent.
这些问题也是我在疫情期间自己生病时问过自己的，当时也是癌症，但我已经幸存下来了。我非常欣赏“设计我们自己的人生”这个概念。我只是想找出一种方法，既能尊重这个过程，又不至于太以自我为中心。有两个非常年幼的孩子和一个依赖我的伴侣，我想确保即使我在审视自己的人生，思考如何做出负责任的选择并重启职业生涯时，我也不会在牺牲对伴侣和孩子的责任的情况下这样做。所以如果有什么问题的话，我想是：我该如何平衡设计我的人生和抓住这个重新开始的机会，同时又不忽视作为伴侣和父母的责任？
So Miguel has been through a lot over the past few years, Dave, and as he said, he also has responsibilities to his partner and to his family, and that means his ability to maneuver for himself might be somewhat constrained. How can people like Miguel still think about designing their paths forward when they have all these responsibilities and constraints? Well, of course they are. We're all constrained. Design thinking is not a magic wand. Design thinking is not the perpetual emotion machine that is suddenly going to, oh, if I design my life, now that's the key and I can get everything I want. No, you can't. That's totally okay. Welcome to humanity. Now what we're saying back to acceptance is I begin. with reality, including the acceptance that I am a finite person. In our recent book, we talk a lot about the three big reframes around impact, fulfillment, and the scandal of particularity. What the heck is the scandal of particularity? It's the recognition like, oh my gosh,
所以米格尔过去几年经历了很多，戴夫，正如他所说，他还要对伴侣和家庭负责，这意味着他为自己腾挪的空间可能受到了一定限制。像米格尔这样的人，在有这么多责任和限制的情况下，还能如何思考设计他们前进的道路？嗯，当然他们会受到限制。我们都受到限制。设计思维不是魔杖。设计思维不是永动机，不会突然间让你觉得，哦，如果我设计了我的生活，那这就是关键，我能得到我想要的一切。不，你不能。这完全没问题。欢迎来到人类世界。现在我们回到接纳，我从现实开始，包括接受我是一个有限的人。在我们最近的书里，我们谈了很多关于影响、成就感和“特殊性的丑闻”这三个大的重构。什么是“特殊性的丑闻”？它是这样一种认识：天哪，
it turns out no ultimate is ever fully experienced, love, beauty, justice, compassion, you name it. We'll never, ever actually see that whole thing in reality. We see temporary flawed, constrained, circumstantial reflections of those things called a particularity, and they come and they go. And then when you realize that, then suddenly you go, oh my gosh, and one of the biggest particularities is me. I am a small expression of the fullness of the thing called me. We will never know the fullness of Miguel. We will simply know the revealed Miguel that he chooses to bring to the world. In the constrained little thing called
原来没有任何终极目标是可以被完全体验的，爱、美、正义、同情，等等。我们永远、永远不会在现实中真正看到那整个东西。我们看到的是那些被称为“特殊性”的暂时的、有缺陷的、受限的、环境性的反映，它们来来去去。当你意识到这一点时，突然你会想，天哪，最大的特殊性之一就是我。我是被称为“我”的那个整体的一小部分表达。我们永远不会知道米格尔的全部。我们只会知道他选择带给世界的那个展现出来的米格尔。在被称为
7 by 24 hours, and the constrained little thing called what Singapore is doing and what his family has, he has boxed himself in, and that's the good news. Because now the design task isn't to transcend that box
7乘24小时的受限小盒子里，在被称为新加坡正在做的事情和他家庭所拥有的受限小盒子里，他把自己关在了盒子里，这是好消息。因为现在设计任务不是要超越那个盒子
or to beat gravity. You can't do that. What you can do is I can make the most of what is. So design, we talk about get more out of your life, not cram more into it. There's nothing missing in his life,
或者去战胜重力。你做不到。你能做的是：我可以充分利用现状。所以设计，我们谈论的是从你的生活中获得更多，而不是塞进更多。他的生活中没有什么缺失，
other than, then deeply accepting the priorities of what he's going to do and what he's not going to do. And once those decisions are made, own them and then get the most aliveness out of them you possibly can. So constraint is actually your friend because it narrows the field of what you have to worry about. I just turned 73. And, you know, past 50, you start losing muscle mass. I'm a motorcyclist and I like to go on motorcycle tours with my soon-to-be wife. And I have a rule.
除了深刻地接受他要做什么和不做什么的优先级。一旦这些决定做出，就承担它们，然后从中获得尽可能多的生命力。所以限制实际上是你的朋友，因为它缩小了你需要担心的范围。我刚满73岁。而且，你知道，过了50岁，你开始失去肌肉质量。我是一名摩托车手，我喜欢和即将成为我妻子的伴侣一起进行摩托车旅行。我有一个规则。
You're not allowed to ride a motorcycle you can't pick up. Well, I've got this great big 600-pound motorcycle. I can barely pick it up. And the time is coming when I can't do that anymore. Is that a problem? No, it's just true. So I'm going to live into it while I can, enjoy the heck out of it while I can, and then I'll do something else. Constraint is not an enemy.
你不允许骑你扶不起来的摩托车。好吧，我有一辆600磅重的大摩托车。我几乎扶不起来了。我不能再那样做的时刻即将到来。这是一个问题吗？不，这只是事实。所以我会在我还能做的时候去享受它，尽情享受，然后我会做别的事情。限制不是敌人。
It's just true. We talked earlier about the parable. of putting too much of our self-worth into the idea that we need to make an impact. We heard from a listener named Brittany who teaches high school orchestra. She often senses that students take orchestra because it looks good on college applications, and she wonders whether her teaching is actually helping students fall in love with music. Here she is. And I had one particular student who was a very fine musician, an all-state violinist,
它只是事实。我们之前谈到了关于把太多的自我价值投入到我们需要产生影响的想法中的寓言。我们收到了一位名叫布列塔尼的听众的来信，她教高中管弦乐队。她经常感觉到学生参加管弦乐队是因为这在大学申请表上看起来不错，她怀疑她的教学是否真的在帮助学生爱上音乐。她在这里。我有一个特别的学生，她是一位非常优秀的音乐家，全州小提琴手，
you know, pleasant to work with in class, but I really thought that I annoyed her. and I really thought that she was just barely tolerating my existence and my enthusiasm for all things orchestra-related. And she gave me a letter at graduation that completely floored me and got me 100% unstuck. Because in her letter, she outlined how much she respected everything that she had witnessed me do in the past several years and how the orchestra program had grown in the few short years that I had been there, how she found it so inspiring to have this experience with a woman conductor. She went on in the letter to write about how she had written about me for her college application essay, which got her into her dream school of Georgetown,
你知道，在课堂上合作很愉快，但我真的以为我让她很烦。我真的以为她只是勉强忍受我的存在，以及我对管弦乐队相关一切事物的热情。她在毕业时给了我一封信，让我彻底震惊了，并让我100%走出了困境。因为在她的信中，她概述了她有多么尊重我在过去几年里所目睹我所做的一切，以及在我任职的短短几年里管弦乐队项目是如何发展的，她觉得有这样一位女性指挥的经历是多么鼓舞人心。她在信中继续写道，她是如何在大学申请论文中写到我的，这让她进入了她梦想中的学校——乔治城大学，
and how inspired she had been every day that she sat in my classroom. I mean, cue the waterworks. I was just completely shocked that I had had this profound impact on the student, and I had genuinely no idea. So I've kept that letter all these years, and I pull it out once or twice a year to remind myself that even when it feels that I'm not making the headway, that I want, either musically or personally, with these students, that chances are I probably am because I had no idea the impact I was having on this student.
以及她每天坐在我的教室里是多么受到鼓舞。我的意思是，眼泪都要掉下来了。我完全震惊了，我竟然对这个学生产生了如此深远的影响，而我根本不知道。所以我这些年来一直保留着那封信，我每年拿出来一两次，提醒自己，即使当我觉得我没有取得我想要的进展时，无论是在音乐上还是个人层面上，与这些学生在一起，很有可能我确实产生了影响，因为我根本不知道我对这个学生产生了什么影响。
So I want to talk for a moment, Dave, about how when we think about impact, we're actually focused on the impact that we can see. We're often not paying attention to the impact that we cannot see. And very often the things that we do can have impact far beyond what we are actually aware of. In this case, of course, Brittany heard from her students, so she found out what was happening in her student's life. But for many of us, the things that we do, many of the things in our day-to-day life, are going to have impacts on people that we cannot possibly ever learn about.
所以我想要谈一会儿，戴夫，关于当我们思考影响时，我们实际上关注的是我们能看到的影响。我们往往没有注意到我们看不到的影响。而且很多时候，我们所做的事情产生的影响远远超出了我们实际意识到的范围。在这种情况下，当然，布列塔尼听到了她学生的消息，所以她发现了学生生活中发生了什么。但对于我们许多人来说，我们所做的事情，我们日常生活中许多事情，都会对我们根本无法了解的人产生影响。
And in some ways, we discount them, and we imagine that we're having no impact. Well, Brittany had a very good day when you get that letter. That's a lovely experience. And that kind of thing does happen all the time. But back to that fully engaged, calmly detached idea, you have to remember you don't know what somebody else is thinking. There's a great line that my late wife used to quote all the time from Rabin Janath Tagorei talking about relationships where he said, you know, the best we can do is to salute one another from the borders of our solitude.
在某种程度上，我们低估了它们，并想象我们没有产生任何影响。嗯，布列塔尼收到那封信时度过了非常美好的一天。那是一种可爱的经历。那种事情确实一直在发生。但回到那个“充分投入，冷静超脱”的想法，你必须记住你不知道别人在想什么。我已故的妻子经常引用拉宾德拉纳特·泰戈尔关于关系的一句名言，他说，你知道，我们能做的最好的事情就是在我们孤独的边界上互相致敬。
He was talking about intimacy. You know, and we were in a marriage. We were talking about that, you know, that we can get incredibly close and an us. But at the end of the day, that other person over there is this mystical combination of spirit and intellect and physicality and somatic reality. and history and DNA and culture. And the truth is, I have no idea what their experience is. And can I remember to respect that? There's always the border of solitude between me and every other person.
他在谈论亲密关系。你知道，我们当时在婚姻中。我们在谈论那个，你知道，我们可以变得非常亲密，成为一个“我们”。但归根结底，那边的另一个人是精神、智力、身体、躯体现实、历史、DNA和文化的神秘结合体。事实是，我不知道他们的体验是什么。我能记得尊重这一点吗？我和每个人之间总是有孤独的边界。
And that shouldn't scare me off. It should simply make me a little humble. So that there's that possibility. I remain a little bit open. I recall a student, every now and then we get a troublesome student. There's a young man who's in a small group. frankly, he was kind of acting out and he was grumpy and difficult and he didn't like to answer the questions and he criticized other people in his group and we kind of hoped he'd drop the class. So I tricked him into coming to office hours where I was probably going to encourage him to drop and it started with, you know, well, how's it going?
这不应该吓跑我。它应该只是让我谦卑一点。所以有那种可能性。我保持一点开放。我记得一个学生，偶尔我们会遇到一个麻烦的学生。有一个年轻人参加了一个小组。坦率地说，他有点表现得叛逆，脾气暴躁，很难相处，他不喜欢回答问题，还批评小组里的其他人，我们当时有点希望他退课。所以我骗他来办公时间，我本来打算鼓励他退课，谈话开始于，你知道，嗯，进展如何？
And I had this incredible experience. He starts and again in this very grumpy, upset way, kind of goes, well, you know, I don't know. I'm just, I'm having such a good time. This thing is really amazing. It's changing the way to think about everything. I'm so glad I'm taking the class, you know. and these other students are really helping me. So, I mean, this, this, I'm like, okay, the soundtrack and the video are really out of sync here.
然后我有了这种不可思议的经历。他开始以一种非常暴躁、不安的方式说，嗯，你知道，我不知道。我只是，我玩得很开心。这东西真的很神奇。它正在改变我思考一切的方式。我很高兴我选了这门课，你知道。这些其他学生真的在帮助我。所以，我的意思是，这，这，我当时想，好吧，音轨和视频在这里真的不同步。
And, but I said, oh, okay. So I did coach him, but I said, no, by the way, and you're kind of struggling with this, aren't you? Yeah, I really have it. Yeah, the struggle part's really evident. In fact, it's kind of overwhelming the joy part, and you're scaring your friends, get you back off a little bit. And he did. But the point being, you know, you never know. And then meanwhile, what that does mean is, let's say Brittany didn't get that letter.
但是，我说，哦，好吧。所以我确实指导了他，但我说，不，顺便说一句，你有点挣扎，不是吗？是的，我确实有。是的，挣扎的部分真的很明显。事实上，它有点压倒了快乐的部分，你在吓唬你的朋友，稍微退后一点。他确实这样做了。但重点是，你知道，你永远不知道。与此同时，这意味着什么呢，假设布列塔尼没有收到那封信。
At the end of the day, do the work, bring your gift, whether or not it lands. You know, there's the old line, you know, that, you know, one plows, one plants, you know, another waters, but God gives the growth. Back in the day when we lived in an agrarian society, we remembered I'm doing my part and it's part of a greater thing. that I'm not in charge of. In the post-capitalistic technologically enabled world, we think we actually can control outcomes, and we can't. You just do the best you can do. I want to play you a story from a listener Laura, Dave. She recently retired from 35 years in education, and in many ways I think her story sums up so many of the ideas you have been talking about. I had many opportunities to work with people that I really appreciated and with, you know,
归根结底，去做工作，带上你的天赋，无论它是否落地。你知道，有一句老话，你知道，有人耕耘，有人播种，你知道，另一个人浇水，但上帝给予生长。在过去我们生活在农业社会的时候，我们记得我尽了我的本分，它是更大事物的一部分。我不负责。在后资本主义技术赋能的世界里，我们认为我们实际上可以控制结果，但我们不能。你只需要尽你所能。我想为你播放一个听众劳拉的故事，戴夫。她最近从教育界退休，工作了35年，在很多方面我认为她的故事总结了你一直在谈论的许多想法。我有许多机会与我真正欣赏的人一起工作，并且与，你知道，
thousands of students over the years who I believe I've impacted in a positive way. That said, I'm not sure that my career really was the fulfillment in my life. And it wasn't until I retired that I discovered that there is no destination that you could call happiness. that you can't set a goal that I'm going to be happy in the future or I'm going to find my life fulfilling when I look back on it. Rather, I've discovered that it's more of a daily journey where I spend time each day making choices that allow me to arrive at the places that give me happiness and make me feel like my life is fulfilling. I volunteer. I enjoy the outdoors. I enjoy cycling. I get outside every day. I spend time with my family, my grandchildren, my friends. And I do
多年来成千上万的学生一起工作，我相信我对他们产生了积极的影响。话虽如此，我不确定我的职业生涯是否真的是我生活中的成就感。直到我退休后，我才发现没有一个目的地可以被称为幸福。你不能设定一个目标，说我将来会幸福，或者当我回顾过去时，我会发现我的生活很充实。相反，我发现这更像是一段每日的旅程，我每天花时间做出选择，让我到达那些给我带来幸福并让我觉得生活充实的地方。我做志愿者。我享受户外活动。我喜欢骑自行车。我每天都去户外。我和我的家人、孙辈、朋友在一起。我做
things that probably I would have never done when I was working full time and just trying to get all the tasks in my life out of the way. I would just hope that everybody gets the chance to make the choices that make each day very happy and ultimately give them a fulfilling life. So I think Laura could take your job, Dave. What do you think? Yep. No problem. Laura has cracked the code. She points out, wait a minute, even though I had the career, the output, the impact, the result, that in and of itself was not first and foremost what my life is about. It's lovely when that occurs. It does matter. Don't get me wrong.
那些我全职工作时可能永远不会做的事情，当时只是试图把生活中的所有任务都处理掉。我只是希望每个人都有机会做出让每一天都非常快乐的选择，并最终给他们一个充实的生活。所以我认为劳拉可以接替你的工作，戴夫。你觉得呢？是的。没问题。劳拉已经破解了密码。她指出，等一下，即使我有了职业、产出、影响、结果，那本身并不是我生活的首要意义。当这种情况发生时，这很可爱。它确实很重要。别误会我。
Having a positive impact, if you can pull it off, is totally worthwhile. But what makes it worthwhile isn't just that result. That result is frankly just the feedback loop. What makes it ultimately worthwhile is I am stewarding this thing called My Life. Her job isn't to be the best teacher in the world. Her job is Laura Ing. And Laura Ing looked good in a teacher form, and now it looks good in a retired form that It includes volunteering and enjoying nature.
产生积极的影响，如果你能做到，是完全值得的。但让它值得的不仅仅是那个结果。那个结果坦率地说只是反馈循环。让它最终值得的是，我正在管理被称为“我的人生”的这件事。她的工作不是成为世界上最好的老师。她的工作是“劳拉·英”。而“劳拉·英”在教师形式下看起来不错，现在在退休形式下看起来也不错，它包括志愿服务和享受自然。
And what we're doing is taking this little chunk of aliveness that we've been given. Now, whatever your philosophy, whether you think God gave it to you or the universe did or DNA give it to, you didn't give it to you. None of us formed ourselves. We've received from somewhere this gift's called an aliveness. And it's up to you to Stuart how to bring it to the world, including just every single day, nurturing that on behalf of yourself and one another. And if you do that well, we all win. She's doing a great job. Dave Evans is a behavioral scientist at Stanford University. With Bill Burnett, he's the author of How to Live a Meaningful Life, Using Design Thinking to Unlock Purpose, Joy, and Flow every day.
我们所做的是利用我们被赋予的这一小块生命力。现在，无论你的哲学是什么，无论你认为上帝给了你，还是宇宙给了你，还是DNA给了你，你并没有给自己。我们都没有塑造自己。我们从某处收到了被称为“生命力”的礼物。由你来管理如何将其带给世界，包括每天都在为你自己和彼此培养它。如果你做得好，我们都赢了。她做得很好。戴夫·埃文斯是斯坦福大学的行为科学家。他与比尔·伯内特合著了《如何过上有意义的生活：利用设计思维每天解锁目标、快乐和心流》。
Dave, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. Next week on your questions answered, Dave Evans responds to your stories of radical acceptance. We also heard today from psychologist Lisa Miller of Columbia University. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
戴夫，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，香卡。下周在你的问题解答中，戴夫·埃文斯将回应你们关于彻底接纳的故事。我们今天还听到了哥伦比亚大学心理学家丽莎·米勒的分享。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
If you enjoyed today's conversation, please consider sharing it with your friends and loved ones. Word of mouth recommendations really help to continue. connect more people with the ideas and research that we explore on the show. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢今天的对话，请考虑与你的朋友和亲人分享。口碑推荐确实有助于继续。将更多人与我们在节目中探索的想法和研究联系起来。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。